une production du studio
SF bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast
où on parle de ce qu'on ve que nos
invités that's it je suis pH quanttin
avec moi Doom plant le retour oh yeah
aujourd'hui le retour de Jeff qu'on a
reçu 2 3 ans puis on avait parlé c
vraiment au cœur de la pandémie puis on
avait parlé de lui en fait c'est un
journaliste chez Radio Canada qui
travaille avec pour l'émission Les
décrypteurs il font beaucoup de
déboulonag de myths puis de fact
checking puis de d'enquêtres dans les
mondes conspirationnistes et et dans le
monde du web en général puis on avait
parlé justement de de de de mouvement
conspirationniste à l'époque puis là on
aujourd'hui on a fait un espèce de
premièrement espèce de où en est euh le
les mouvements conspirationistes
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui en reste de de
de ce ce ce CES mouvementslà qui ont qui
ont vraiment pris de l'ampleur dans la
pandémie euh on voulait aussi lui parler
euh en fait lui euh comme on disait il
journaliste chez Radio Canada puis là
maintenant on sa ma bloque les
publications qui viennent euh de de de
de de journaux de de de médias de médias
euh crédibles donc comment ça les
affecte puis pourquoi en fait pourquoi
qu'on en est là comment ça fonctionne le
projet de loi C1 c'est quoi euh en fait
qu'on a parlé ben bah c'est ça de de
l'impact puis de de de de ces compagnies
là tout le pouvoir qu'ils ont on a parlé
aussi a d'intelligence artificielle chat
GPT mid journey puis c'est quoi en fait
selon lui l'impact que ça va avoir dans
le le futur puis nous moi j'ai exprimé
mes craintes par rapport à tout ça puis
c'est vraiment ben c'est un gars qui
connaît son son son sujet Comment on dit
c'est toujours fascinant d'en apprendre
sur toutes ces domaines là puis Jeff qui
est quand même optimiste malgré tout par
rapport au futur par rapport aux
technologies puis ça fait quand même du
bien parce que ça peut devenir
angoissant comme on dit fait que on vous
souhaite un bon podcast bonne écoute le
podcast est présenté par vidéo créateur
pro c'est une formation en ligne pour
apprendre à développer ses aptitudes en
vidéo que ça soit la capture des images
comment fonctionn les caméras et de
montage tout ça si vous pensez que
d'être capable de produire des belles
vidéos peut vous servir puis je pense
que ça peut servir à vraiment beaucoup
de monde en 2023 d'être capable de faire
des belles vidéos que ce soit juste pour
faire du beau contenu sur vos réseaux
sociaux ou pour votre business pour
votre job pour euh toutes sortes de
raisons qu'on voudrait faire des vidéos
vidéos intimes peut-tre peut-être
imagine tu suis la formation pour faire
vraiment des vidéos
avec incroyabl vidéos ton partenaire ou
ta
partenaire et la formation c'est quoi
c'est 45 minutes ou est-ce qui vous
donne les leur 10 meilleures astuces
quand je dis il je parle de il c'est qui
il c'est Henry et Niri de la compagnie
hxn qui est une compagnie de production
vidéo puis là vous dites ou mais c'est
qui les autes c'est des professionnels
ok nous avec le studio C on a travaillé
avec eux on a fait faire une vidéo de
promotion du studio avec eux ça a été
vraiment on était vraiment vraiment
satisfait c'est impeccable et on
travailler avec moi aussi à mon nom
personnel avec sport expert on avait une
collaboration avec sport expert pu
c'était qui avaient été mandaté de faire
les vidéos incroybles il ont travaillé
avec oitier cosmétique il ont travaillé
avec la Croix Rouge donc il connaissent
leur affire puis ce qu'ils veulent faire
en fait c'est rendre accessible des
techniques professionnelles pour que vos
vidéos aent l'air pro fait si vous
voulez plus d'information déjà plongé
dans cette formation là le lien va être
dans la description du podcast fait
merci aux boys pour nous faire confiance
merci à vous de supporter ceux qui
supportent le podcast
c'est gratuit fait que comment refuser
dur à manscape c'est l'heure de parler
de manscape avez-vous des balls des
balls ah bon blague à part
mancapeapcap c'est une compagnie de
produits pour hommes qui font toutes
sortes de produits pour le
soin de le probl tracer en fait de votre
pilosité ou votre hygiène personnel
votre peau hein votre peau juste pour
pour être bien dans le fond euh on vous
parle aujourd'hui du ultra smooth
package ce que c'est c'est un package en
fait c'est un principalement un rasoir
un rasoir ma foi très agile et très
précis et vraiment qui qui qui est conçu
en fait principalement pour la région
des bijoux de famille comme on pourrait
dire
poiment on commence la publicité en
disant B pour les régions de famille
qu'on pourrait dire puis dans ce kit là
il y a d'autres choses je vaisen parler
ouais dans ce kit là en fait il y a le
gel il y a le gel pour raser sans
irriter évidemment vous savez que cette
région là irrité ceux qui en ont une une
région de même ok irrité ses poches
c'est très littéralement poche quand la
poche est irrité c'estes poches puis
ensuite on a un exfoliateur
pour s'assurer d'éliminer les poils
incarnés puis parce que ça aussi un poil
incarné sur le
sachet il y a pas grand chose de pire
que ça ça c'est le tout ça vient dans
l'ultra package si vous voulez vous le
procurer ou procurer n'importe quel
autre produit de nos préférés chez
pouuer le code promo sans filtre 20 % de
Rabet livraison gratuite puis c'est tout
ce que vous allez avoir besoin pour
l'entretien sous la ceinture merci merci
à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cool ça roule merci d'être là fait
plaisir merci pour l'invitation un bout
le grand
retouremp beaucoup de choses qui s
passé c'est ça j'ai envie de te demander
comment va ta santé mentale depuis qu'on
vu la dernière fois on s'est vu pendant
la pandémie dans le fond dans le gros de
la pandémie gr ouais c'est ça ex quand
j'étais venu ici il fallait porter des
masque tout oua si je me rappelle bien
c'est pas un petit bout là c'est drôle
c'est une question que je reçois quand
même assez souvent ouais ouais non non
ça va bien tu sais
honnêtement je fais abstraction des
réseaux sociaux le plus possible tues
capable ouais ouais ou ouais ouais ouais
on trouve des façons de des y a des
moments qui sont moins faciles que
d'autres mais écoute ça fait ça fait
partie de la job malheureusement parce
que toi tu sais ta job c'est un peu
d'analyser puis de connaître l'Internet
mais il faut que tu ched aussi
l'Internet à un certain point là faut
c'est j'ai encore encore une addiction à
Twitter jeis pas combien de fois j'ai fa
l'application veux dire ah ouais écoute
le site c'est encore twitter.com c'est
vrai ah ouais ouais mais ouais tu je
sais pas ça fait combien de fois que
j'ai j'ai pass j'ai passe l'application
puis c'est quoi que tu trouves
particulièrement toxique sur internet en
ce moment M et ben question large mais
ça dépend toujours des des plateformes
tu sais sur Twitter bon
malheureusement il y a une toxicité dans
le propos on le voit il y a beaucoup
d'insultes il y a
beaucoup de troll puis maintenant que
tout le monde est capable de s'acheter
un crochet
bleu puis leur ce qui pas làdedans c'est
que les G gens qui ont crochet bleu leur
réponse au commentairire apparaît en
premier en premier donc il ont plus de
visibilité donc ça ça fide làdedans ça
encourage moi jeer mes commentaires ça
fait un boot dans le fond personne peut
commenter sur mes postsess commenter à
amener parce que je trouvais ce que av
partagé intéressant je vouis faire genre
je voulais dire job ou genre thumbs up m
de quoi
positif là j'ai fait ok je comprends
écoute c'est c'est vraiment euh c'est un
compromis tu sais c'est vraiment plat
parce que la plupart des gens voudraent
commenter de bonnes fois puis je me suis
le fait dire tu sais c'est comme c'est
vraiment plate je voulais juste
commenter puis je peux pas euh mais en
même temps c'est pas vrai que je vais
passer mes journées à modérer mes
commentaires puis là tu sais ce que je
me suis rendu compte c'est que il y a
des gens qui venaient me défendre puis
il argumentaient avec les trolls pu ça
finissait plus là ça fait juste leur
donner plus de visibilité ça ça leur
donne qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent tu sais
dans le fond euh puis ça les expose à
mone ahistoire qui est souvent beaucoup
plus gros que l'heure
fait que tu sais si réussisse à fâcher
les gens qui me suivent puis là il y a
des chican dans les commentaires ça fait
juste les aider puis j'ai beau dire aux
gens argumentz pas avec eux ouais c'est
en tout cas c'est à moins que tu modèes
vraiment de façon très serrée tes
commentaires tant qu'à moi je pense
c'est mieux de c'est mieux des bloquer
surtout que moi je bloque personne sur
sur Twitter parce que je suis
journaliste payé par Radio Canada et
donc par le citoyen je pense quand même
que les gens ont le droit de voir
qu'est-ce que je publie tu sais fait que
je bloque person
pour le moment puis puis c'est quoi en
fait qui en B français trigger les gens
comme ça c'est que toi tu fais du fact
checking un peu puis tu fait du fait ça
attire les gens qui sontaccord ou ou
surtout pendant pandémie c'est développé
un genre de d'attitude que je travaille
pour le gouvernement je suis là pour
défendre que ce soit le vaccin ou peu
importe j'ai quasiment je pense pas j'ai
écrit d'article sur le vaccin proprement
dit c'est ça qui est drôle mais bon il y
a cette cette attitude là qui qui s'est
développé tu sais en fait une semaine et
demi une semaine et demi je me suis fait
crier après par quelqu'un dans la rue
ouais quelqu'un qui une dame là qui m'
ouais qui m'a reconnu puis était comme
pas était pas juste en délire là
savait comm décrypteur puis put du
gouvernement puis et cetera tu sais
ouais je sais a c'est pas il y a pas une
raison pour to ça y a beaucoup
de beaucoup de colère qui a été provoqué
par les mesures sanitaires par la
pandémie par les conditions économiques
par tout plein de facteurs là c'est
plate que ça se manifeste de cette
façonl ouais honnêtement je travaille
pour aider les gens pour les aider à
avoir la meilleure information possible
pour qu'il puisse prendre les meilleures
décisions puis sais si taime pas mes
articles F mais genre ce niveau
d'agressivité là c'est un peu un peu
regrettable quand qu'on s'était parlé en
fait on sais c'était just au cur de la
pandémie puis on Ava parlé beaucoup de
conspirationisme tu sais puis
aujourd'hui le podcast parlera pas
principalement de ça mais est-ce
que on en est où aujourd'hui par rapport
à ça est-ce que c'est ce mouvement là
est encore bien en santé ou plutôt on
c'est vraiment plus plus au calme que
c'est lestèv là 2 3 ans c'est une grosse
question ça ça atteint un niveau de
popularité qu'on avait jamais vu avant
la pandémie je pense là tu sais ça a été
quasiment mainstreamé tu sais difficile
à mesurer c'est choses là parce que
toujours eu des gens qui ont eu des
sortes de croyan tu sais dans les années
90 là il a plein de monde qui croyait au
aux ovnis puis aux extraterrestres des
choses comme ça l'assassinat de JFK ou
des choses comme ça tu sais ça a tout le
temps eu une certaine traction là ce qui
arrive ce qui est arrivé avec la
pandémie c'est que des gens sont tombés
dans diverses conspirations pour plein
de
raisons par exemple à propos que le le
vaccin il y
a a quelque chose là qui modifie notre
Ren pour nous faire mal ou des choses
comme ça là quand il tombe là-dedans ils
se mettent à tomber dans d'autres puis
d'autresis d'autres là c'est tout est
connecté ensemble là c'est tu sais le
Forum économique mondial veut créer des
des 15 minutes Series pour nous
contrôler pu qu'on aura pas le droit de
sortir de notre quartier puis tu sais
c'est il y a comme un effet d'entrain
sais quand tu rentres là-dedans ça
encourage d'autres puis c'est quelque
chose qu'on voit beaucoup c'est il y a
des gens qui malheureusement tombent
là-dedans puis il reste un peu pogné
là-dedans fa que ceux qui étaient pognés
là-dedans ils sont encore sont encore
une chose qu'on a remarqué j'ai vu juste
juste sur ça là rapidement j'étais
j'étais à Otawa en fin de semaine puis
je courais devant le Parlement carrément
où est-ce qu'il y avait les le convoi de
la liberté qui était allé s'installer
puis il y avait un doue qui était assis
là puis j'ai fait la joke à ma blonde je
fa ce là il doit être assis là depuis
depuis la pandémie là jamais parti par
qu' était assis là il y avait un
amplificateur à côté de lui un moniteur
de de son puis parlait dans un micro
puis faisait juste
déblatérer des théories du complot genre
longtemps puis c'était crissement
polluant parce que tu es comme devant le
Parlement le coucher de soleil genre des
touristes qui prenaient des photos pu
tuas le gars qui faisait juste nonstop
rambl des des des conspirations comme
débile mental tu sais puis là tu dis ok
non lui il est jamais sorti de ça tu
sais il est pasevenu de ça ouais pour du
monde ça Devi un peu ça devient leur
identité tu sais une chose que je dis
souvent c'est que la pandémie a blessé
beaucoup de gens puis sais il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont de très bonnes
raisons d'être en maudit pour le monde
dans lequel on vit qui vraiment pas
parfait que le système il craque par
bout tu sais puis il y a vraiment des
doléances qui sont légitimes pourquoi
est-ce que le système de santé était
aussi brisé tu sais qu'on a été obligé
de mettre en place des mesures pour le
sauver sais par exemple c'est des
questions qui sont légitimes fa légi ou
l'affaire c'est que
il y a des gens qui se sont retrouvés à
faire partie de communauté en ligne puis
il ont trouvé quelque chose qu'il avait
pas avant tu sais tuas des gens que des
gens monsieur madame tout le monde la
vie tous les jours qui se sont mis à
donner leur opinion sur le vaccin sur
les masques puis tout puis qui des gens
à qui on a jamais demandé leur opinion à
propos de quoi que ce soit puis là tout
d'un coup c'est des stars dans leur
cercle sont dans les groupes facebook
quand ils écrivent des choses il ont des
centaines de likes des gens qui écent
dans les commentaires oui tu as raison
puis il ont l'impression deire partie
d'un faire partie d'un mouvement sont
entourés d'une communauté c'est super
séduisant ça pour quelqu'un qui avant la
pandémie était sur facebook posté une
photo de sa nièe puis elle avait 5 likes
elle va pas retourner en arrière là elle
est là-dedans puis c'est son style de
vie pu c'est son identité tu sais c'est
je veux dire l'addiction aux réseaux
sociaux c'est une vraie chose j'en
parlais juste tantôt que moi-même je
suis partiellement tu sais addict aux
réseaux sociaux quand tu te mets écrire
des choses puis ça un certain succès
puis G cl honnêtement c'est c'est comme
une drogue tu sais puis gris fait il y a
des gens qui restent pgnés là-dedans
parce que c'est devenu vraiment
carrément leur style de vie leur
identité j'ai l'impression qu' des gens
aussi tu sais par exemple moi j'ai un
ami que tu sais je connaissais plus
longtemps puis tu sais avant la pandémie
c'est c'est tout le temps éta le gars
qui était un peu antiouvernement un peu
antiapitaliste mais que çavait pas de
réel impact sais dans la vie de tous les
jours dans le sens que on est amis on
faisait de la musique ensemble puis tout
était good puis là c'est comme si la
pandémie si tu avait déjà une petite
tendance soucieuse des autorités du
gouvernement ben là ça ampli amplifie ça
fois 1000 ben c'est ça pu là il y a un
faussé qui se creuse puis là ça a des
réelles répercussions dans vraie vie de
tu sais de entre si te fais vacciné ou
non
vraiment des décisions de vie
importantesou mais tu sais c'est ça
c'est dans la vie de tous les jours on
on confronte pas très souvent l'autorité
gouvernementale tu sais comme c'est rare
qu'on se f qu'on se fasse arrêter pour
la plupart des gens ou tu sais que on a
interagit avec la police ou le système
de justice ou quoi que ce soit puis là
ben on a tous été confrontés à
l'autorité gouvernementale au quotidien
de à chaque jour quand tu sortais de
chez vous tu avais un signe évident d'un
certain pouvoir étatique faut tu mettes
un mas faut que tattendes en ligne pour
aller à la pharmacie faut que tu sortes
une application pour aller au restaurant
des choses comme ça donc c'est je dire
pour des gens qui avaient déjà une
grande méfiance envers l'autorité mais
c'est sûr que ça les a vraiment affronté
à ça là à chaque jour puis pour des gens
ça les a vraiment vraiment mis en colur
maintenant que le l'espèce de cheval de
Bat de la pandémie est derrière nous tu
sais pour les ben dans le sens il y a
plus de de restriction sanitaire Mons
qui était comme la grosse affaire à
suivre ton ton compte Twitter on dirait
qu'il y a certains mouvements
conspirationnistes qui maintenant tu
sais l'expression anglaise grasping at
straws là ou est-ce que là il essaie de
de trouver des des nouvelles
conspiration à mettre le leur énergie
dedans puis toi tu partages souvent des
des affaires qui ont comme aucune crise
de sens puis qui sont super facilement
comme démontable tu sais est-ce que
est-ce que tu as remarqué cette espèce
de tendance de faire et là on peut plus
critiquer ce qui est évident ce que tout
le monde vit fait que là on faut
utiliser cette tribune là parce qu'on
veut continuer à voir les lik que tu
parlais tantôt parce qu' on est rendu
accro à
ça faut trouver autre chose tu sais
ouais ben c'est ça c'est c'est drôle que
tu c'est une chose qu'on a remarqué au
décrypteur c'est nous on on essaie de
surveiller ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux sociaux puis il y a aussi
beaucoup de gens qui nous écrivent pour
dire j'ai vu ça passer sur facebook tu
est-ce que c'est vrai est-ce que c'est
pas vrai là c'est on a pas d'études
scientifiqu pour prouver ça c'est
vraiment anecdotique mais nous ce qu'on
a remarqué c'est le message ce que les
gens appellent conspirationniste il il
sort plus de la la bulle en gros c'est
on dirait que la population générale a
fait genre tu te mets à parler de vaccin
puis il arrête d'écouter tu sais au
début de la pandémie tu avais des choses
qui
sortaient des grosses désinformations
puis tuas des gens sincèrement tu pas
pas des gens qui qui croient n'importe
quoi juste des gens ordinaires qui
voyaient ça puis était comme ah c'est
vrai puis était vraiment inquiet on voit
beaucoup moins en ce moment on ça sort
plus puis comme tu as dit là je pense
qu'il y a comme des tentatives d'aller
chercher des nouvell des nouveaux
auditoir la pandémie ça marche plus
parce que les gens ont pas mal choisi
leur camp puis la la majorité des gens
bon sont allés se faire vacciner puis
ils ont mis ça derrière eux on dirait
qu'il y a une tentative d'aller chercher
des nouveaux histoir fa que là c'est
tout le temps à chaque fois qu'il y a
une grosse nouvelle mais là c'est c'est
pas vrai à chaque fois fait que là les
feux de forêt qu'on a vu cette année
mais c'est des lasers qui avait tu
partageais une affaire complètement
débile qu' un gars qui disait qu'il
avait pu corrige-moi si je me trompe si
je raconte mal l'affaire le gars il
disait qu' avait plus de Bage bleue ou
de veste bleue mett d'un Rona d'un Home
Hardware parce que les le bleu ça
protégeit contre les lasers qui ont mis
le feu au forêt des feux de forêt puis
qu' avait une attaque qui se préparait
le 23 septembre exact c'est fou ça là
mais c'est ça c'est
ça faut faire a plus de bleu je pe pas
protéger je veux dire tu racontes ça à
une personne qui est pas sur Internet
sont comme de quoi tu parles de quoi
parles de quoi tu parles mon pèreant mon
père il pas Facebook pas Twitter mon
père il fait juste vivre sa vie à
l'extérieur d'Internet là je raconte ça
il va même pas même pas être capable de
comprendre c'est ça même pas être
capable de comprendre le début de ce que
j'étais en train de dire là là non c'est
ça puis c'est comme tu sais j'aiécrit un
article là-dessus ça a appris que 750
mots juste pour expliquer pourquoi
est-ce que le dou a fait une vidéo de ça
la faire c'est que la vidéo c un
montréalet qui a fait ça il disait qu'il
y avait plus de bâche bleue au Rona puis
il essaie de bloquer la vente de ça
whatever euh 1 million de views sur
TikTok c'est ça l'affaire c'est ça que
tu dis aussi l'affaire c'est qu'il y a
combien de gens là-dedans que il croit
sincèrement ou qui ont juste écouté ça
parce qu'il trouvent ça drôle tu sais je
veux dire faut pas faut pas non plus
écarter ça tu
sais il y a du monde pour qui regarder
des conspirations c'est c'est comme
regarder un film c'est
divertissementis avant de travailler
là-dedans ça m'arrivait des fois d'aller
sur le le redit conspiracy tu sais puis
juste de voir ok c'est quoi les théorie
bizarre que les mondes que que les gens
inventent tu sais puis c'est sans y
croire c'est juste que il il y a quelque
chose de divertissant pour certaines
personnes donc je dis pas qu' un million
de personnes ont cru à ça mais quand
même c'estis c'est fou les c'est fou l'
que ça atteint tu mentionnais dans dans
ce post là ou ou dans un autre je me
rappelle plus mais
comment TikTok plus que plus que jamais
de Facebook ou de
Twitter c'est pernicieux parce que on n
pas une vue d'ensemble de l'application
parce qu'il y a pas de il y a pas de
reshare de partage mettons dans dans les
gens que tu suis fait que c'est juste ça
apparaît dans ton fil que tu le vois
dans le fond puis tu puis tu disais que
c'était ultra perniciux de ça parce
qu'on avait pas la vision de ça mais moi
il y a des affaires que je suis tombé
sur tik tookok que je j'en revenais pas
metton de ce que je voyais là tu sais il
y a un gars tu sais évidemment Andrew
Tate on le connaît on sait on sait à
quel point c'est c'est c'est de la merde
son affaire mais j'ai vu un
Québécois qui était habillé exactement
comme Andrew Tate avec genre les
lunettes de soleil là pu là il il il
avait des propos que j'ai jamais genre
j'aurais jamais pensé qu'en 2023 on
pouvait parler comme ça encore pu
parlait de de une mère ordinaire là ok
bien pr puis là il a fait une vidéo
c'était débile mental jamais vu
quelqu'un avoir genre je revenait pas
que ça existait mais j'en avais jamais
entendu parler j'avais jamais tu sais vu
ce personne dans mon entourage avait
fait un post sur Facebook en disant ça
c'est débile parce que ça existait pas
pourquoi je me suis fait proposer bonne
question mais dans les commentaires C
just du monde qui était comme ah je suis
d'accord avec toi je suis d'accord avec
toi je suis d'accord avec toi là j'ai
comme fait ok non siil y a ça qui tombe
par hasard dans mon feed imagine ce
qu'il a là de h il y quoi qui pass ça
pas de sens là ouais c'est que TikTok
c'est une plateforme qui est quand
même bizarrement constru c'est 100 %
algorithmique comme tu l'as dit tu sais
tu peux la question me suis posé c'est
comme OK pourquoi ça ça m'est présenté
ex des fois des fois l'goritthme il
tente des choses il t'envoie quelque
chose pour voir si tu V m à l'ameçon
puis il fait des tests comme ça c'est ça
qui est difficile vraiment comme tu
disais c'est difficile d'avoir une vue
d'ensemble de ce qui se passe làdessus
tu sais sur Facebook sur Twitter un peu
moins maintenant depuis que Elan mask
l'a acheté mais tu as des outils qui
permettent de voir bon regarde ce post
là tu regardes toutes les post au Canada
c'est lesquels qui performment le plus
puis tu peux faire des recherches par
terme TikTok il y a pas ça encore euh
tout le monde est dans leur propre
algorithmique algorithme euh puis ben
souvent tu sais les TikTok c'est vu
comme une plateforme pour les jeunes
fait peut-être qu'il y a des chercheurs
des journalistes des gens qui
surveillent ces genre de choseslà vont
peut-être moins aller sur TikTok puis
quand ils sont ils vont peut-être pas
regarder ces choses-là donc mais c'est
assez euh on a fait le test sur décp on
a créé un nouveau compte TikTok il y a 2
ans puis tu sais en D de 20 minutes
c'était juste du compte cétait carrément
juste du contenu qui était extrême là
c'est facilement tu fais un like sur une
affaire débile puis tu es tu pas juste
des lik c'est le temps d'écoute tu sais
si si tu t'arrêtes sur une vidéo tu le
regardes un peu plus longtemps
l'algorithme comprend que ça te plaît
fait jour il y avait une vidéo
excuse-moi non c'est bon l'autre jour av
j' avais juste mis une vidéo C genre une
fille qui sort de de la salle de bain
puis qui pète sur son chum puis là là je
l'ai juste laissé sur le comp pendant
que je Allis me brosser les mais j'ai
comme pas fermé l'application ou quoi
que ce soit la vidéo joué sur repeat là
pendant une soirée au complet là c'était
juste des vidéos de monde qui se pè
dessus mais tu sais c'est ça c'est c'est
fou par exemple parmi les contenus les
plus populaire au Canada en ce moment
c'est des des gens qui disent qu'il
veulent quitter le Canada parce ça coûte
trop cher Arve pas à se loger pu il y en
a plein c'est des vidéos qui ont des
millions de views les gens sont le
Canada est brisé tuas beaucoup des
Vidéos de Des N arrivants qui sont comm
venz pas au Canada ça vaut pas la peine
j'ai le goût de quitter fait en écoutant
des vidéos de même TikTok c'est m à me
suggérer de gens qui quitte le Canada
mais pas pour des mauvaises raisons de
comme des vidéos de gars qui sont comme
ben je quitte le Canada parce que je
m'en vais étudier en Angleterre
l'algoritthme comme compris qu'il y a un
lien alors que thématiquement ça aucun
rapport mais gen on descend jusqu'au
Mexique à VO non c'est ça fa que ouais
c'est ça ça te pousse vraiment
rapidement là dans il t'oriente parce
que c'est c'est passif TikTok c'est ça
l'affaire tu sais comme Facebook ça
peut-être aller dans tes groupes ou tu
sais ça je pense qu' beaucoup de gens
ont com lâcher Facebook là je sais pas
pour vous
mais tu sais oui tu vas regarder ton
wall défilé mais tu vas aller cliquer
sur le profil de ton ami ou tuas aller
dans un groupe avoir des discussions
TikTok c'est vraiment 100 % passif c'est
swipe swip swip swip présenter les
choses puis c'est ça qui ça exaement
c'est le doom scrolling là qui appelle
déjà scroll finini genre puis tu t'en
rends comme pas compte ça m'arrive
maintenant faut que je me check vraiment
parce que sinon je suis en parti pour
des heures mais c'est comme tu sais dans
les années 80 le monde il zaap à TV puis
tu sais tu choisissais pas qu'est-ce qu'
joue à TV
tu appiches qu que tu trouves quelque
chose c'est juste que là c'est du
contenu qui il y a pas vraiment de
standard tout le monde peut mettre du
contenu là-dessus puis sur TikTok je
pense que la modération
assezile ça dépend pourquoi si tu mets
de la nudité sur TikTok ou ça ton compte
est effacé instantanément si tu
critiques certaines politique du
gouvernement chinois il y a certaines
indications que ton compte va soir Fermé
ou ta vidéo va être retirée si tu tu
utilises des mots violents comme kill ou
euh tu sais même des mots comme sex ou
des choses comme ça euh ça va être
censuré donc quasiment immédiatement euh
mais si tu donnes des des des conseils
de santé fucked up à des gens puis tu
leur dis de boire du borax qui est un un
produit pour euh pour laver les lavabau
là c'est la grosse mode sur TikTok c'est
d'en mettre un peu dans ton eau puis le
boire pour détoxifier ton corps là ça ça
passe il y a pas de problème il
absolument pas de problème c'est fou ça
pu c'est ça que tu sais tu me disais je
pense juste avant qu'on qu'on se met
enregistrer tu là maintenant avec le ban
des des médias d'information sur sur M
tu me disais TikTok il y a pas de Ban
puis l'information objective et vérifiée
est pas nécessairement plus présente et
gagnante versus désinformations c'est ça
les médias ont le droit de publier sur
TikTok ça marche plus ou moins les
médias ont quand même de la misère à
percer là-dessus c'est une plateform qui
est faite pour tu filmé toi-même tu sais
les les gens veulent plus voir des vrais
gens euh puis moins du contenu qui est
vraiment léché produit par des médias tu
sais il y en a des médias là-dessus là
puis il y en a qui réussissent à à faire
des choses qui fonctionnent mais le
contenu non médiatique est infiniment
plus vaste puis plus populaire
malheureusement fait oui les Médi ont de
la misère à à se faire un chemin sur
TikTok pour le moment euh mais
l'information continue de circuler les
gens vont faire des vidéos voici les
cinq choses que vous devez savoir cette
semaine puis il y en a qui vont il y en
a qui vont mettre de l'avant des sources
d'information fiable ils vont mettre des
vont parler d'articles de journaux des
choses comme ça il y en a qui mettent
leur spin il y en a qui inventent
carrément des affaires donc tu sais
c'est c'est un peu c'est un peu free for
all puis moi ce qui me désempar c'est
comment les gens sont prêts à
vraiment faire confiance à n'importe qui
tu sais comme tu un gars qui dit oh les
feux à hawaaii tu sais Oper Winfrey sa
maison a pas passé au feu puis genre ça
veut dire que ça a été plinifié d'avance
parce qu'il la maison pas brûé tu mal
c'est
clair sa maison était pas dans une
région où il y a eu des feux mais bon ça
c'est secondaire
ou le P que j'ai vu sur TikTok c'était
ma collègue Brigitte Noël d'enquête a
sorti un reportage gros en cas qui a
pris un an et demi à faire qui
exposait un homme qui avait agressé
sexuellement des des adolescentses il a
un gars qui met met une capture d'écran
son article derrière lui puis est comme
regardez les médias en parlent
pas Artic de médiia c'est comme où
est-ce que tu as pris ton information
B mais c'est commia not genre pu c'est
comme parce que littéralement c'est un
article de journal derrière de journal
de Radio Canada der à toi mais mais
c'est ça c'est c'est tellement aïe Aï
mais c'est parce que tu
sais l'information sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est présentée de façon
identique à tout l'aut toutes les autres
contenus a des photos de choc des des
billets de blog qui des des caricatures
qui des vidéos drôles fait on a
l'impression que ce contenu sort de
nulle part tu sais comme les nouvelles
il existent comme si quelque chose
arrive dans société on va le savoir il y
a quelqu'un qui va en parler sur réseaux
sociaux puis je va le savoir sans penser
au fait que ben si personne n' produit
cette information là tu vas pas le
savoir tu vas jamais le savoir il y ait
tu sais c'est c'est ça la transmission
fait de bouche à Rê tu voir des gens qui
parlent de sujet d'actualité qui ce sont
très clairement informés auprès de
médiia parce que le gars sur le gars sur
TikTok il est pas allé au
Parlement regarder la période de
question puis voir qu'est-ce que le
gouvernement a dit à propos du projet de
loi mais il en parle tu
sais tu vu qu'est-ce que trudau a dit
mais parce que tu sais c'est des
journalistes qui ont fait en sorte que
tu le sais ça ça mais les gens comme
l'impression que l'information ça sort
ça pousse d' arbres ça sort de par si
quelque chose arrive dans société je
veux le savoir désolé c'est pas comme ça
que ça fonctionne parce que moi quand je
pensais puis que je pense encore àé
juste laisser mon sel de côté mon juste
arrêter ça parce que ça me crée beaucoup
d'anxiété puis je travaille avec ça mais
mais je me disais ma réflexion ça a été
de me dire ben
ça va pas me tomber dessus là qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans le monde puis je veux
pas devenir complètement aveugle de la
la réalité je veux pas juste être
oblivie à tout ce qui se passe puis
penser que tout va bien m mais en même
temps je me disais si je laisse mon seul
côté comment je va avoir cette info là
puis après ça je me suis je pourrais
juste acheter un journal avoir un
journal qui arrive chez moi puis là le
matin lire le journal mais c'est ça qui
est drôle c'est comme on dirait que les
gens dans le temps compris que il les
nouvelles c'est bon mais avec une
certaine dose puis tu avais ton journal
Le Matin qu'est-ce qui se passe tu Liss
déjeunant après ça tu penses tu
continues ta vie puis peut-être le soir
en suent tu regardes le buletin de
nouvelle pour voir ce qui s'est passé
dans la journée puis d' genre tuas pas
tu es pas 24 he sur 24 en train de
regarder qu'est-ce qui se passe à la
seconde près puis on le voit il y a
vraiment un épuisement de de nouvell
sais comme on a tous été collés sur
l'actualité pendant les trois dernières
années pour savoir qu'est-ce qui se
passait avec la pandémie la en Ukraine
toutes les tensions sociales qui a un
peu partout en accident puis il y a
beaucoup de monde qui malheureusement il
drop sais sont juste comme garde je suis
plus les nouvelles genre ça me cause
trop d'anxiété puis je veux juste plus
savoir ce qui se passe dans le monde je
m'en fous c'est vraiment plate c'est ça
le cycle de nouvelle 24h à la seconde
près que qui a été créé par la
télévision en Contin continu puis
ensuite par le fil d'actualité en
continu des des réseaux sociaux c'est
peut-être à repenser comme façon de de
présenter l'information ouais on a reçu
coupe de semaine de Dominique Tardi qui
est à la presse là puis tu sais lui
disait que là il y a vraiment un effort
conscient du journal de comme essayer de
produire des nouvelles qui sont aussi
positives mainant parce qu' disait que
là il y a il y a un épuisement le monde
sont comme sont comme plus capables pu
ils veulent plus lire les nouvelles
parce que c'est juste c'est c'est trop
lourd là tu sais c'est juste la
négativité fait que non c'est sûr qu' un
effort conscient d'essayer de raverser
la vapeur sinon le monde est désabonn
c'est ça qui est plate avec avec les
nouvelles c'est que les nouvelles c'est
souvent négatif c'est il y aura pas
d'articles de nouvelles sur genre madame
côté é allé à l'épicerie elle a acheté
sa bouffe aller cuisiner à la maison
puis a passé une belle soirée en é
Netflix avec son chum tu sais commeouis
mais la plupart des choses qui se
passent dans la vie c'est ça la grande
majorité 99,999 % du temps c'est ça
c'est ça c'est les nouvelles c'est pour
être une nouvelle faut que ça soit
exceptionnel puis il faut que ça soit
quelque chose euh qui a un impact sur la
vie puis tu sais c'est ça c'est rarement
des choses que bon ben euh aujourd'hui
euh tout tout va correct que c'est sûr
que ça a un certain BIA que les
nouvelles c'est souvent négatif puis
c'est souvent ça joue sur les émotions
tu sais veux veux pas euh c'est c'est
c'est c'est jamais euh c'est jamais du
banal tu sais h HM dans les les C
dernières années mettons à suivre euh
l'actualité puis l'Internet surtout euh
qu'est-ce qui te qu'est-ce qui te fait
le plus peur entre guillemets pour les 5
prochaines c'est quoi mettons la
technologie ou la tendance on on peut
parler de d'intelligence artificielle ou
quoi que ce soit qui toi tu fais comme
peur d'un point de vue sociétaire en
faisant ça c'est il y a vraiment risque
de tomber quelque part là point de vue
technologique ou juste en général ben tu
peux aller où tu veux avec ta question
dans le fond là ben tu sais c'est sûr
que la
on sent une fracture dans la société qui
est vraiment profonde puis tu as
beaucoup de gens qui il ont pas
juste sont pas juste critiques envers
les institutions envers le gouvernement
c'est carrément c'est fini tu sais puis
on on sent qu'ils veulent plus
participer à la vie civique euh donc ça
devient ça devient vraiment agressif
dans le fond c'est que c'est comme mais
regarde les élections ça sert à rien par
c'est
tu sais m'impliquer auprès de C social
ça sert à rien parce que j'en su toute
contrôlé par le for économique mondial
ou des pédophil des satanistes des
choses comme ça puis il y a vraiment une
une agressivité profonde puis c'est
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour euh aller
parler à ces gens-là pu ce qui est PL
c'est que ces gens-là s'isolent non
seulement du reste de la société mais de
leur proches souvent
sais ces gensl les gens qui me crient
après sur les réseaux sociaux souvent
j'ai goût de leur dire mais savez-vous
comment vous faites mal à votre famille
je le sais parce qu'il m'écr tu sais
puis on en reçoit des courriels de gens
qui sont comme je sais plus quoi faire
ma mère je peux plus parler chaque fois
que j parle se met à crier à propos de
Donald Trump tout c'est je veux juste
souper ouais puis ça les blesse pour
vrai pu on en reçoit tout le temps des
histoires
de de personnes que leur famille ont été
brisé par ça sais puis c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment c'est tant au niveau
psychologique niveau social je sais pas
ce qui va arriver comme il y a eu une
grosse il y avait déjà une brèche dans
notre société avant la pandémie la
pandémie est venu vraiment l'ouvrir
ouais là c'est une plaie tu sais euh je
sais pas comment on la répare cette plie
là euh puis tu sais on voit tu regarde
qu'est-ce qui se passe aux États-Unis
par exemple c'est pas en voie de
réparation c'est la la brèche elle est
très très très grave tu sais c'est c'est
c'est c'est carrément rendu du dénis de
la réalité il y a plus moyen de de
de ramener des gens à des valeurs qui
sont communes sais comme à une autre
époque un candidat à la présidence qui
se ferait accusé de d'avir essayé de
voler une élection çaarrêté la fin de sa
candidature on passe autre chose là
c'est Donald Trump vend des t-shirts
avec sa photo de sa photo de
booking c'est quelque chose qu'on aurait
jamais vu avant comment est-ce que tu
Ratt pi 235 livres 3 ouais mais je sais
pas comment est-ce que tu rattaches des
gens des gens qui trouvent ça cool que
Donald Trump a été arrêté quasiment aux
gens qui trouvent que c'est vraiment
extrêmement grave ce qui s'est passé on
dirait qu'il habite même plus dans la
même société tu sais tu habites le même
espace géographique mais tu habites plus
dans la même société tu as plus les même
référent commun tu as même plus les
valeurs communes je sais pas j'ai
honnêtement aucune idée comment on fait
pour par que en fait tu de plus en plus
la vie est virtuelle les gens habitent
l'Internet finalement puis chacun peut
occuper son propre territoire de
l'Internet puis jamais côtoyer quelqu'un
d'autre puis se retrouver ensemble
là-dessus là tu sais c'est rendu quent
le où on se situe c'est quasiment plus
virtuel maintenant que quasiment que
géographique ouais exactement
puis ça aussi c'est c'est une
conséquence de la pandémie dans le sens
que ben on était forcé à avoir le peu de
d'interaction sociale qu'on avait
c'était par le biais d'Internet ça a
changé aussi la façon dont les gens
socialis fait tu sais ou en tout cas
c'est c'est un c'est un gros problème tu
sais c'est mais c'est c'est pas juste
internet c'est pas c'est pas Facebook
qui a créé ça là tu sais c'est pas c'est
pas Donald Trump qui a créé ça c'est pas
c'est vraiment ça fait longtemps c'est
multifactoriel la la base de confiance
envers toutes les institutions c'est
généralisé là puis c'est extrêmement
complexe comme problème c'est pas c'est
pas quelque chose que ah ben tu sais si
tout le monde lche Facebook pu Twitter
tout
h on est trop loin de ce côtélà j'ai
l'impression c'est ça c'est on est allé
on est trop loin là en ce moment il y a
vraiment c'est vraiment profond ouais
ouais puis on on recevait aussi Frédéric
Gagnon aussi pour nous parler des des
partielles américaines 1 an je pense
puis lui il nous disait qu' qu' avait
vraiment vraiment qui avait qui
appréhendait beaucoup les prochaines
élections parce que si si Trump ne
gagnait pas aussi les répu gagnait pas
il avait vraiment peur qu' de quoi de
comme vraiment grave qui se passe aux
États-Unis là c'est sûr que le le le
temps monte euh ce qu'on voit vraiment
aux États-Unis c'est c'est quasiment
quand je dis il y a plus de on a comme
mis côté la la bonne foi puis le genre
de valeur commune de comme garde on on a
peut-être pas les mêmes opinions mais on
est quand même citoyen du même pays puis
tu sais il faut quand même avoir un
minimum de
respect c'est c'est plus ça aux
États-Unis c'est le niveau d' le niveau
d'agressivité quand même incroyable tuas
des des gens pro Trump qui sont
carrément tu sais ça va être les armes
là tu sais ça est-ce que c'est juste la
rhtorique pour aller chercher des des
followers sur les réseaux sociaux tu
sais je sais pas si ça va
vraiment ça l'a été les armes dans le
sens que ce qui s'est passé au capital
c'est
littéralement on prend les armesis on
même là sais même là je me rappelle je
regardéis en direct quand c'est arrivé
puis j'avais le sentiment de de de
regarder l'histoire en direct puis de
voir quelque chose qui est extrêmement
grave ça a duré de jours le genre de ok
c'est allé trop loin c'est dangereux ce
qui est arrivé on on se calme ça a duré
de jours à peu près puis après ça c ah
ben non mais c'est c'est antifa qui a
fait ça non c'est le FBI qui a fait des
agents infiltrateur ah non mais cé
c'était pas du FBI mais genre c'était
légitime comme
comme comme manifestation c'est rendu
que c'est chez certaines personnes aux
États-Unis les gens qui se sont fait
arrêter pour pour ce qui s'est passé au
capital on l' vu cette semaine il y a
leader des proud Boys enriqueio qui a
Copé de 22 ans de prison ce qui est
quand même
sérieux c'est comment mais c'est c'est
un prisonnier politique c'est pas il y a
eu rien de grave c'est pas c'est pas
grave puis s qu' bien des
gens pour qui c'est c'est c'est leur
opinion là sais c'est hm hm donc c'est
ça c'est il y a le même événement qui a
eu lieu dans le même espace géographique
puis tu as deux univers complètement
différent qui voit la chose complètement
différente de façon complètement
différente ouais ouais c'est inquiétant
ouais puis est-ce que tu sais j'imagine
que une des manières de Ben de contrer
la désinformation c'est de rendre
l'information disponible puis là tu sais
euh tu sais c c'était une des des choses
que je voulais parler avec toi qu'on
voulait parler avec toi en tinvit ici
c'est tu sais le justement le ban de de
sur MTH des des est-ce que est-ce que ça
t'inquiète ça est-ce que ça un impact
majeur tu trou sur la la portée de de de
votre travail ou ou pas tant que ça je
sais pas mais j'ai pas des chift sur
qu'est-ce que ça représente
comme comme baisse de
trafic je pense que pour la part des
médias il y avait de de toute façon
moins de trafic qui prenait de Facebook
de moins en moins sais Facebook jouer
avec son algorithme au cours des
dernières années pour prioriser moins
les nouvelles plus les publications de
tes amis puis et C c'était déjà quelque
chose qui était en cours de route si on
se fit à Facebook les nouvelles c'était
quelque chose comme 3 % du contenu ou
moins que ça sur leur plateforme ça
c'est selon leur chiffre je sais pas
j'ai pas accès à leur chiffre interne
donc c'est une minorité là mais on est
d'accord que je pense que c'est une
minorité de contenu que les nouvelles
sur facebook euh le problème c'est que
ça crée un vide tu sais c'est c'est
c'est que c'est ça c'est que tu te
retrouves une situation ou tuas des gens
qui pour qui Facebook c'est l'internet
ça c'est une chose qu'il faut pas
nécessairement oublier tu sais pour des
gens qui connaissent un peu plus
l'Internet on va aller sur internet avec
tu sais Firefox ou Chrome ou tu sais
safari on va aller sur des sites on va
aller voir ce qui se passe on a
différentes applications qu'on va
utiliser pour bien des gens Facebook d'
là c'est ils ont l'application Facebook
sur leur iPad euh puis c'est ça
l'Internet pour eux en S jamais ou très
peu ils comprennent pas tant ce qui se
passe à l'extérieur de ça tu sais comme
on on sous-estime l'impact que les iPad
ont eu sur l'adoption d'Internet par des
gens un peu plus âgés ouais on leur a
mis un P des mains on a dit voici
Facebook tu vir suivre tes petits
enfants mais aussi le Journal de
Montréal puis là ben ils sortent pas de
ça pour eux c'est s Internet puis je
pense que pour eux malheureusement ben
ils sont laissés pour compte il y a pas
je dire c'est non seulement les les les
pages des grands médias sont bloqué puis
même pas juste des grands médias là
plusieurs de plusieurs plus petits Médi
tuas même des des journaux étudiants qui
ont été bloqués mais tu peux même pas
partager de lien vers vers un média
d'information donc je dire comme je
disais tantôt les gens s'informment de
toute façon fait que ça va être du
bouche àay puis ben le bouche à ça va
être de qualité variable tu des gens qui
vont écrire des posts sur E j'ai lu dans
le journal de Montréal tel affaire tu
sais allz aller checker sur le site
c'est c'est de l'information qui est
fiable mais on sait bien là le Bou c'est
çai je direen j'en lisais les articles
de Radio Canada du devoir de de par
rapport à tu sais provenant de mon
facebook puis j'ai pas le refélexcement
d'aller sur les sites de ces médias là
pour voir c'est quoi d'actualité moi
j'ai j'ai réalisé quand c'est arrivé
j'ai réalisé que je prenais mon
information là carrément parce que
pendant 2 semaines j'avais aucune idée h
ce qui se passait ouis j' comme puisé
j'ai réalisé jeis àépicerie je me
rappelle j'ai réalisé que là j'ai aucune
idée de c'est quoi qui se passe gen j'ai
vraiment aucune idée fait que j'ai
commencé à utiliser on a command qui
commandit podcast qui s'appelle infobref
qui envoie une infolette à chaque matin
avec des informations puis j'ai fait ok
ben là je v tu sais j'étais déjà abonné
mais je regardais pas tout le temps les
les infolettes j'ai fait chaque matin
première chose que je fais je regarde ça
me prend 5 minutes j'ai au moins cette
information là ouais fait je fais j'ai
fait l'effort supplémentaire de faire de
me ré de réaliser que j'avais plus
d'information qui se rendait jusqu'à moi
dans le fond non c'est sûr c'est sû sais
là on parle de méta qui est une chose il
y a aussi Google qui envoie des signaux
que potentiellement il voudrait bloquer
les médias canadiens ça je pense c'est
un peu plus
inquiétant tu pourrais pu chercher sur
googleit pas dans les recherches de
Google fait ça c'est en tout cas ils ont
pas encore mis ça en
place duébec façon mon me de
recherche c'est c'est la loi la loi
C18 bon la raison pour laquelle M décidé
de bloquer les médias canadiens c'est
pas encore en vigueur ça entre en
vigueur en décembre h tu peux nous
expliquer c'est quoi cette loi ouais
dans le fond c'est une loi qui force les
grandes plateformes à payer des
redevances aux médias canadiens pour le
contenu le contenu qu'on produit fait si
il y a un post Facebook
avec un lien Radio Canada il devrait
payer pour ça tu verser verser un
certain montant au médiia l'idée
derrière ça c'est euh de de de d'aider
le financement des médias surtout étant
donné que Facebook Google ça capare une
très très très très grande proportion
des des des revenus des publicités en
ligne pu que ça fait mal au médias ouais
euh puis ben
euh les grandes plateformes on dit ben
non absolument pas donc Facebook a
décidé mthod décidé carrément bloquer
les médias
canadiens Google semble indiquer que eux
aussi vont aller en ce sensl euh pu
c'est ça Google ça serait je pense plus
grave parce que beaucoup de gens ils
vont pas écrire l'URL d'un site là ils
vont ils vont aller dans leur barre de
recherche vont écrire Radio Canada puis
ils vont cliquer puis là ça ça vous
amène à Google tu sais puis là ben il
clique sur le site de Radio Canada tu
disais tu sais tu disais pour des gens
Facebook internet mais genre pour
beaucoup de gens aussi Google c'est
l'innetou ou juste tu es sur Chrome tuas
juste besoin d'écrire un mot dans barre
de recherche tombes sur la M je veux
savoir je sais pas qu'est-ce
qui Paul SaintPierre
plamondon'est gen vois juste pas tuas
aucun article à part gen Wikipédia dans
le fond tu vas tomber sur
wikipéiacune nouvelle d'actualité de
qu'estce qu' a fait non c'est
ça en tout cas on sait pas exactement de
quoi ça vair avoir l' mais tu aurait pas
l'ACT l'onglet actualité dans Google
puis tu sais mais comme tu dis tu sais
tu peux avoir des scénarios où tu as une
élection puis là quelqu'un comme mais je
veux savoir c'est quand le débat tu sais
tu écris dans Google puis tu as rien
ouais ça pourrait arriver tu sais ou
juste juste les gens pourra avoir de la
misère à carrément trouver le site web
des c'est comme c'est pas tout le monde
qui connaît les adresses des des sites
web sa laprice.c est-ce que tu sais que
c'estc et non.com
c'est ça pourrait poser problème ça
c'est c'est vraiment un entrave quand
même assez grave à la recherche
d'information surtout quand on dit Parô
de de du peu de nouvelles sur MTA mais
du peu de pourcentage de contenu
pourcentage de nouvell sur Google
j'imagine que c'est la même chose je
sais pas j'ai pas de chip làdessus le
rapport de force est pas là là tu sais
c'est c'est quand même c'est quand même
stock ouais mais c'est le rapport de
force il est entre les plateformes puis
le gouvernement canadien exa euh je
pense que ce qui est arrivé c'est bon il
y a déjà eu un projet de loi semblable
en Australie il a quelques années
Facebook avait fait la même chose il av
dit on bloque les nouvelles arties
australiennes puis finalement se sont
réavisés après un certain moment
gouvernement australien non
le puis là finalement ils ont réussi à
négocier quelque chose avec le
gouvernement australien je suis pas un
expert sur cette voi là je veux pas vous
ind en erreur mais il y a eu une entente
puis finalement les les nouvelles
australiennes sont disponibles sur
facebook aujourd'hui euh je pense que ça
peut-être été vu comme c céit un bluff
de la part de Facebook de bloquer les
nouvell puis au Canada il ont dit bon
ben garde il bluff ils vont bluffer
encore finalement je pens peut-être pas
un bluff en ce sais ça pourrait se
résoudre demain là
mais quand j'en vois des des
porte-parole de mé dire
ben les nouvelles c'est très
peu c'est c'est très peu de ça
représente très peu de notre trafic puis
en plus les gens nous dis disent qu'ils
veulent voir moins de nouvelles sur leur
fil d'actualité que les nouvelles c'est
à cause de la chicane que genre les gens
veulent moins voir ça veulent plus voir
des des choses à leurs amis tout je
pense que tu sais c'est ça le rapport de
pour eux finalement de faire ça semble
selon leurs chiffres selon leurs
chiffres non c'est sûr que ça ça leur
cause quand même un dommage à leur image
de marque je pense là c'est de voir des
plateforme jouer au gros bras comme ça
c'est pas tout le monde qui trouve ça
cool que Google MTH compag californienne
viennent ici puis disent ben tes
citoyens auront plus accès aux nouvelles
sur notre plateforme sa il on faitel que
ça vaut de jouer plus fort avec des
gouvernements c'est quand même c'est
quand même pété pareil quand tu penses à
ça tu sais des compagnies
privées ça soit à ce niveau là de de
négociation c'est ça tu d'un
bar tu as eu des observateurs qui
disaient depuis des mois qui dire le
projet de loi ça ça va pas marcher c'est
mal ficelé c'est c'est vague c'est pas
une bonne idée c'est pas la bonne
manière de de s'y
prendre d'un autre B tuas des gens qui
sont comme ouais mais c'est pas normal
que des multinationales puissent venir
carrément jouer dans notre vie civique
en jouant les gros bras puis en venant
dire ben pas de nouvelle
d' il est peut-être possible d'avoir les
deux opinions en même temps aussi on
dirait que c'est un peu l'un ou l'autre
là sais je dire moi je je suis loin
d'êre expert mais tu sais juste l'idée
que les que les médias soit rémunéré
pour les clics qui proviennent de
facebook puis de M genre ça me paraît
comme comme une bonne avenue là tu sais
mais puis là je te demande pas ton
opinion à toi mais je ve dire les gens
qui critiquent ce projet de loi là c'est
quoi les arguments fond c'est que c'est
ça reste quand même très vague
que on on avait pas les paramètres
exacts tu sais puis c'est peut-être pas
la bonne manière de se prendre il y
avait rien pour forcer le gouverne il y
avait rien pour forcer cet argent là à
financer directement les activités des
médias bon bref euh il y a des gens qui
s'y connaissent beaucoup plus que moi
euh mais ça a été quand même vraiment
pas unanime là ce projet de loi là on on
va laisser ça de même euh mais c'est ça
euh mais mais tu sais en même temps tu
dis les clics provenant des médias mais
mais c'est l'inverse qu'est-ce ve dire
dans le sens les les le monde est sur
Facebook ouais puis il clique vers le
média pour lire l'article vers le média
fait c'est dans ce sens là que le clic
se fait tu sais c'est des clics qui
arrivent au médias de Facebook c'est pas
c'est aussi Facebook qui profite du fait
que c'est du contenu qui est sur leur
truc puis le monde y vend pour parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils vont consommer ce
contenu là puis il veulent le voir ouais
mais essaie de quantifier ça puis de
donner un tu un versement pour le nombre
de personnes qui utilisent Facebook pour
aller voir les nouvelles pour aller sur
le site après c'est comme c'est c'est
c'est en tout cas bref on certaines
personnes qui sont de la vie que les
médias jamais être sur Facebook en
partant puis que gen un peu mettre le
contenu des médias sur ces plateformes
là gratuitement c'est un peu shake a
hand with the devil ouais oui en se
disant on va utiliser Facebook pour
aller chercher promotion c'est ça ouis
mais en même temps ben tu donnes ton
contenu à ces plateformes là tu donnes
un headline puis une photo mais tu sais
ça c'est une boîte de pend tu reviens
pas en arrière puis là les gens ont déjà
leurs habitudes de VI demandz aux gens
he euh ok arrêtez de vous informer sur
facebook là là genre chaque matin
choisiss choisissez-vous abonnez-vous à
un ou deux journaux idéalement ouaisouis
puis euh aller voir le site le matin
pour voir les les grands titres ça tu
demandes aux gens de changer leurs
habitudes puis puis d'achouter un autre
abonnement encore dans leur euh ouais
déjà quand les abonnements en ver tu as
des abonnements pour tout là abonnement
Netflix tout le mone ouais je veux dire
c'est c'est difficile on a comme pour
assez Esser d'aller chercher l'istoire
sur un Internet où tout est gratuit on a
habitué les gens au fait que
l'information est gratuite puis
disponible en tout temps puis ben c'est
ça c'est un peu comme sais quand je
mentionnais tantôt que beaucoup de gens
ont comme l'impression que les nouvelles
sortent de nulle part ben on a comme un
peu participé à ça en mettant notre
contenu disponible gratuitement sur les
plateformes ça on dirait que ça sort de
nulle part ouais fait que c'est ça c'est
quand quand quelque chose est gratuit
puis disponible n'importe quand tu y
accordes moins de valeur ouais c'est
vrai puis après ça c'est impossible
c'est pratiquement impossible deevenir
en arrière non parce que des gens qui
vont de l'information gratuite ou puis
les autres vont le faire n'importe
comment qu'il veulent B c'est ça exact
puis depuis depuis justement que les que
les nouvelles sont bloquées ça c'est tu
la panique à l'interne ou ou pas la vie
continue puis on écoute je pense je peux
pas vraiment commenter sur se passe à
l'INT can r Canada mais dans les médias
général est-ce que ça bouleverse toutes
les système ou c'est oh ben ça change
pas grandchose on continue comme on
continue mais je sais que tu sais il y
avait certaines inquiétudes surtout avec
les feux de forêt en Colombie
Britannique que les gens auraient de la
misère aller trouver d'information
fiable à propos par exemple des des
mesures de faut évacuer puis là la
personne est chez eux sur son iPad à
descendre Facebook
puisvacue ce que je comprends ça semble
les gens ont quand même partager
l'information de bouche à dans des
groupes locaux puis tu sais on on se
sont entraidés comme ça euh mais c'est
sûr que bon tu déjà les Médi qui ont été
malmenés par l'avénement des réseaux ben
premièrement l'avénement d'Internet
deuxièmement l'avénement des réseaux
sociaux pu ça ça ajoute une couche de
plus tu sais c'est
euh en plus de c'est ça d'être d'être au
centre d'une guerre entre le
gouvernement puis des des
multinationales c'est c'est ça c'est
c'est c'est pas la meilleure situation m
pour
dire ouais c'est du stock pareil c'est
c'est on dirait que on dirait que plus
ça avance plus c'est plus plus la la
technologie les médias sociaux puis plus
ça avance on dirait plus ça va vers vers
le Wild West là on dirait que c'est on
dirait que c'est vraiment le Far West là
dans dans dans tout ce que ce qu'on voit
tout ce qu'on entend puis c'est
difficile de penser à une résolution je
peux être optimiste ben vas-y s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît parce que là j'
retourner jusqu'à Québec avec la gueule
be non mais tu sais ça fait plusieurs
années là qu'on parle que le web dans
lequel on vit le web 2 est mourant là tu
avais il y a quelques années tu avais
les toutes les partis de la crypto qui
dis le web 3 c'est la nouvelle affaire
ça va être avec des NFT ça va être mais
je dis pas nécessairement que c'est ça
qui va arriver puis les soufflement de
la crypto disons porte à
croireut plus rapidement qu'on pensait
lesoufflement de la crypto on en
reparlera mais il ont quand même mis le
doigt sur quelque chose c'est que le
modèle actuel de l'Internet de
l'Internet semble plus fonctionner tu
sais je sa pas vous avez remarqué
l'Internet devient de moins en moins bon
tu sais comm on disit tantôt les prix
augmentent pour les Netflix les crave et
cetera tuas des choses comme uber que ça
coûte de plus en plus cher tu sais a
plein de services auquels on
s'habituer fonctionne moins biennb que
ça coûte des ça coûte fucking cher puis
il faut que tu sortes ta propre poubelle
puis que tu fasses ton lit en sortant
exa exact as desas des services de
streaming service de streaming
maintenant qui lance des ballons d'essai
de mettre des pubs pendant les films des
choses comme ça donc on revient à un
modèle comme la télé en fait là tu sais
si tu vas écouter ton film Netflix puis
il y a trois pub pendant ben ça c'est le
modèle de la télévision bref je pense
que même le modèle podcast tu sais genre
non on met des pubs on met des pubs au
milieu on met des pub à fin on met des
pubs au début tu sais il y a de la pub
c'est ça il y avit pas de pub d' podcast
là il y a de la pub on sent qu'il y a
quelque chose qui est en train de briser
je pense qu'avec les réseaux sociaux
c'est un peu ça aussi c'est quand tu
parles aux gens souvent sont chitané les
réseaux sociaux c'est toxique j'ai plus
le goût de me chicaner avec mon oncle à
propos des vaccins j'ai plus le goût de
voir des OP on veut garder ça pour Noël
ouis comme dans le bon vieux temps un
peu trop sous à
Noël c'est ça ve plus que ça soit leur
quotidien anecdotiquement je vois
plusieurs gens de ma génération en tout
cas délaisser Facebook quasiment
totalement ou tu sais totalement les
générations plus jeunes sont quasiment
plus là-dessus il utilise Messenger pour
s'envoyer des messages mais bref je
pense qu'on il y a peut-être un point
auquel les réseaux sociaux vont devenir
tellement rempli de n'importe quoi de
toxicité de mauvaises informations de
crap que ça devient effectivement
inutilisable puis là avec l'avèement de
choses comme chat GPT euh la génération
automatique de contenu de vraiment
mauvaise qualité ça pourrait on pourrait
bien arriver à un moment où genre tu es
sur Twitter tu sais même plus si tu
interrog avec des êtres humains ou non
c'est rempli de texte tout croch ça
juste faire comme regarde ça se peut que
ça revienne comme avant que les gens
décide d'aller sur des sites web parce
que je le sais que si je v sur tel site
web je sais qui écrit cite web là je le
sais je connais les gens derrière ça ou
quelque chose de nouveau qu'on a pas
encore on n pas encore pensé parce que
c'est quelque chose de révolutionnire je
sais pas mais on sent vraiment que le
statut qu sur internet ça commence à ça
commence à se fatiguer tu sais tu as
raison quand tu dis que l'Internet est
rendu mauvais comme c'est c'est plus
c'est plus une expérience positive c'est
plus une expérience le fun non plus sur
Internet les services sont comme plus
sont plus intéressants non c'est c'est
un phénomène que l'auteur canadien cor
Doct appelle inchification donc la
l'emmerdissement ouais c'est comme cette
tendance là de grande plateformes qui
dispose de monopole ou des quasiment de
monopole de juste rajouter des services
en enlever tout le temps jouer avec la
bébelle pour essayer d'aller sortir le
maximum de profit de la machine euh puis
ça donne comme ça comme résultat c'est
que ces services là auquels on s'est
habitué qui étit euh super bon gratuit
ou vraiment moins cher que les
équivalents dans la vraie vie
soudainement commence à être moins bon
tu sais puis je pense que beaucoup de
gens le sentent ça là il y a quelque
chose qui on dirait que l'Internet est
en pas pas il explose pas mais tu sais
ça frise un peu ses bares puis tu le
sens là que ça marche c'est plus on est
plus comme en 2010 là ou
genre sa Facebook c'est vraiment cool
tout le monde est là-dessus puis genre
ouais c'est il y a comme quelque chose
qui se TR je pense mais le fait que ça
soit tu sais je veux dire l'Internet
maintenant c'est c'est tout là tu sais
dans le sens que avant il y avait un
monde l'Internet existait tu p tu y
allais tu te connectais tu y allais mais
là je veux dire l'Internet il est
omniprésent il est tout le temps là on
est tout le temps connecté puis tout
fonctionne avec l'innet j'ai
l'impression que c'est ça finit par
aussi être retour à la C départ dans le
sens que si tout est internet rien ne
lit là dans le sens que tu sais ça pr ça
en note pour faire des bumper stickers
si tout est internet rien ne l' dans le
sens que ça ça va revenir justement tu
disais ben là les c'est comme si le
modèle la télévision revient parce que
parce que finalement il a
j'ai l'argent finit par mener le monde
puis c'est comment qu' monétise les
affaires pu c'est comment puis j'ai
l'impression que c'est ça finalement ça
ce qu'on avait gagné en ayant une genre
de compétition entre l'Internet et le
non internet finalement si l'Internet
devient le monopole de la vie ça
redevient un peu de la donpe ouais mais
c'est ça la vie redevient la vie la vie
c'était de la donp pu l'Internet devient
la une coupe d'anné va falloir se
trouver quelque chose d'autre qui va
être la prochaine affaire qui sera pas
de la tu pas la vie ni l'Internet un un
autre bumper sticker
ouis non mais c'est tu sais ouais tuas
vraiment un bon point tu sais c'est ça
fait comme 12 ans de peut-être depuis la
crise économique de 2008 2009 que il y a
plein d'argent pour les investisseurs à
investir dans des compagnies comme uber
comme doordh comme Netflix comme toutes
ces compagnies là c'est c'est quasiment
de l'argent gratuit que genre ils
peuvent investir puis le modèle d'affa
de ces grandes compagnies là cétait on
pas besoin de faire de profit on est
juste à aller chercher le plus
d'utilisateurs possible puis un jour on
va pouvoir avoir un profit parce qu'on
va avoir tellement d'utilisateurs qu'on
va être un monopole puis là on pourra
charger ce qu'on veut tu sais puis fait
c'est quasiment puis y a ce concept là
qui appelle en anglais c'est le
millennial life subs c'est comme comme
si le style de vie millénial avait été
subventionné par ces inves
puis on a eu plein de de de de services
de produits à B prix c'était pas
profitable mais on s est habitué puis là
la facture puis c'est beaucoup de
grandes compagnies maintenant ben ok là
les investisseurs commencent à dire ben
là je veux mon cash tu commen à être
profitable puis là ben les prix montent
le niveau de service baisse puis donc sa
on on a vécu un peu dans la dernière
décennie comme dans une genre de bulle
protective dans sur tu c empré quasiment
là ben tu sais moi sa j'aivolu dans le
monde de la musique là tu sais puis
spify je veux dire c'est débile que ça
existe quand tu y penses pas les faire
dans le sens qu'on avait un modèle qui
fonctionnait j'ai le goût d'écouter cet
album là ben je faut que je l'achète
puis je l'écoute puis des revenus de cet
album là qui va à personne puis là c'est
comme tout d'un coup c'est sûr si tu me
donnes toute la musique du monde
gratuitement tout le monde va
s'inscrireou puis là toi tu veux pas
manquer le bateau parce que tu veux que
le monde écoute écoute ta musique puis
tout le monde est là-dessus fait que tu
mets ta musique tu vends ton arme
justement tu fais un impct avec les AR
en mettant la musique là-dessus mais
c'est comme il y a juste quelqu'un qui
qui a eu l'idée j de comme ben si je
fais ça tout le monde va aller là-dessus
les artistes onont plus d'argent puis
moi je vais faire des milliards de
dollars puis c'est comme c'est comme
c'est quiment de la triche quand tu
penses mais ça bon s que ça soit ça
puisse exister là sais on laisse ça
aller c'est comme oui c'est ça
maintenant c'est fou c'est tu peux
vraiment aller chercher les gens quand
tu offres quand tu facilites leur vie tu
peux charger quasiment ce que tu veux
sais tu regardes des choses
comme Steam la plateforme pour jouer au
jeux
vidéo ça vrai vraiment vraiment réduit
le piratage de jeux vidéo pourquoi juste
parce que c'est simple tout est la même
place tu avais plus besoin d'aller au
magasin acheter un jeu vidéo tu peux
juste avec un clicacheter il downlo ton
ordi il fait la job tout seul là tu peux
jouer en 15 minutes sa juste rendre la
vie facile aux gens les compagnes de
jeux vidéos sont prêts à payer 30 %
steam juste pour ça tu sais c'est comme
c'est vraiment quand tu vas faciliter la
vie aux gens là les gens sont prêts à
payer l' mme si c'est même si comme tu
dis avec faire ouais pour les artistes
c'est pas mais je veux dire il y a
quelqu'un c'est ça il y a quelqu'un qui
paye à quelque part quelqu'un qui
désavantage à quelque part puis tu sais
quand c'est des créateurs c'est c'est
triste oui mais en même temps il y a des
créateurs qui se font découvrir par qui
que tu sais moi mettons j'irais pas
ncessement acheter l'album de toutes les
artistes que je découvre sans les avoir
entendu jamais tu sais c'est ça c'est en
même temps c'est ça la vie des artistes
est facilité parce que tu mets ton album
làdessus MP3 puis d' n'importe qui qu
l'écouter pu ach bien pour le show là
sais mais c'est ça oui en effet tu sais
Spotify a un un monopole quasi virtuel
là-dedans puis ben c'est ça ça ça ça
donne jamais rien de bon pour les petits
artistes des artistes comme comme Taylor
Swift tu sais il en profite de spêtre
pas pire quand mêmeement qu'elle a un
deal spécial aussi là tu sais des
artistes d' même qui qui ont qui ont
tellement de Stream qui ont probablement
un pouvoir de négociation vraiment plus
grand que que le petit artiste qui met
sa musique là-dessus puis tu sais puis
tu sais c'est que il y a du monde que je
connais qui ont des millions de stream
là tu sais pas faire de 200 écoutes
statoun là des millions puis c'est comme
le un million de Stre tu vis pas de ça
là c'est des millions de fil tu vis pas
de ça tu sais c'est quand même c'est
quand même capoté tu sais puis tout bref
c'est sûr qu'après ça il y a d'autres
manières de monétiser ton truc mais je
pense que pour versus nom de personnes
qui écouté la mettons la même
musique la musique so autant écoutter le
20 ans pu aujourd'hui je pense que
l'artiste aujourd'hui probement qu' vit
moins bien probement pu sais quand tu
vois après ça que ben là mett il achète
Joe Rogan 300 millions tu dis c'est pas
parce qu'ils en ont pas d'argent je il
en on de l'argent mais il mettent
ailleurs tu sais que payer les relevan
pour les artistes non c'est ça fa
que c'est c'est là qu'on a tu sais je
pense un thème de la discussion
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est justement des
grosses compagnies qui en jou l' sais
Spotify peut se permettre de dire à des
artistes ben garde je vais te donner 3
scèes pour un million de stream parce
que je suis la seule plateforme tout le
monde est làdessus fa si tu veux pas que
personne écoute ta musique c'est fine
mais mais est pas sur mais est pas sur
Spotify pas obligé un G c'est pas obligé
des albums mais tu sais c'est quasiment
rendu quasiment tout le monde a Spotify
tu es obligé de le mettre moi tu vois
puis tu sais les artistes il ont quand
même un pouvoir parce que justement tu
sais Johnny Mitchell enlevé ses euh
toute sa musique de Spotify dans le fond
en partie à cause de de Jo Rogan puis
elle a sorti tu sais elle a fait un
genre de show c'est son premier
spectacle en 20 ans show live puis il
sur Apple music pas sur sptify je meis
abonné à Apple music pour pouvoir
l'écouter puis là maintenant je une
auditeur Apple music tu sais fait tu
sais il y a quand même c'est sûr que là
désabonné tu pas les faire pas encore fa
je le fasse Double Take là il y a des
applications pour ça qui désabonn mais
mais pour dire que tu sais jeux dire
monsieur madame tout le monde ou
l'artiste émergent a pas ce pouvoir là
mais tu sais il y a quand même un
pouvoir là tu sais de de de faire
quelque chose pour pour cont ça ouais
mais c'est ça c'est qui pour continuer
sur ma lignée optimiste euh je pense pas
que ces services là vont s'aller en vont
s'en aller en
s'améliorant en tout cas on voit déjà
que ça les services commencent à être
moins bon fait peut-être que les gens
vont juste arrêter de utiliser ces
grands monopoles là peut-être reste à
voir je pense que tout est possible mais
tu sa il y a une chose je pense que
quiment tout le monde est d'accord c'est
que les gens du web gèent mal leur
affair tu parles des gens de gauche ils
disent que Twitter ça a plein de plein
de suprim BL tu par des gens de droite
sont comme on se fait censurer comme
tout le monde est fâché sur comment ces
plateformes là gère
ou les discussions sur a quasiment
personne
qui ça c'est un point gen c'est vraiment
un point contention vraiment fort c'est
je pense que une bonne proportion des
gens réalisent que l'Internet est
contrôlé par ces géants là c'est
peut-être pas nécessairement une bonne
chose donc est-ce que ça augure un
changement
potentiellement qu'en estil la promesse
du web 3 la trè version web qui qui qui
annonçait une une genre de de
décentralisation puis de reprendre le
contrôle avec la crypto entre autres les
NFT qu'est-ce qui est arrivé avec ça
parce que il y a eu un énorme vent dans
les voiles puis dernièrement ça ça
semble avoir éas ouais
l'effondrement de l'écosystème de la
crypto de l'année passée c'était assez
incroyable voir ça se développer se
déployer en temps réel il y a eu deux
gros crash toi tu suivais beaucoup ça en
ouais exactement à l'époque on
j'enquêtais sur une compagnie de crypto
qui s'appelle Celsius dans laquelle la
Caisse de dépôt et placement du Québec
avait investi 150 millions de dollars US
toutes sortes de questions sur cette
compagnie là comment ils font leur
argent puis bref le le le le PDG a été a
été arrêté pour fraude il y a un mois à
peu près il y a eu deux gros crash un
après l'autre donc au printemps 2022
puis ensuite le gros FTX l'année passée
qui FTX est quasiment devenu là
euh la compagnie de crypto la plus
connue donc une des plus grosses
échanges de crypto au monde qui en
l'espace de 62 he c'est complètement
évaporé c'était une des plus grosses
plateformes finies il ont tous les gens
qui avaient de l'argent sur cette
plateforme là c'est bloqué là sont sont
en faillite euh le P j'ai un ami qui a
perdu ses économies avec ça ou ouais ça
se peut qu'il puisse avoir de l'argent
là parce que là le processus de faillite
est en cours puis ça
ouais il y a beaucoup de gens puis je
voyais
euh dans le processus de faillite les
les gens qui ont perdu de l'argent on le
droit d'envoyer des lettres au juges
pour tu sais pour montrer leur
motivation tu sais puis tu tu lis des
histoires d'horreur là des des gens que
c'est comme je sauvais de l'argent pour
je sauvais de l'argent pour la naissance
de mon bébé puis genre mais j'ai plus
j'en ai plus tu sais c'est bloqué là ça
se peut que les gens retrouvent un
certain pourcentage de leur dépôt parce
que FTX vaut pas Z0 dollars ils ont
quand même encore des actifs qui peuvent
être liquidés euh mais ça ça peut
prendre des années puis on sait pas
combien d'argent va les gens vont
pouvoir aller chercher fait ce qui est
arrivé c'est que FTX éétait la compagnie
la plus en vue il y avait des
commerciales au super bow FTX tu avait
un stade à Miami FTX FTX Arena euh il y
avait des toutes sortes deal avec des
célébrités euh c'était vraiment en vue
puis cétait c'était vendu comme la place
sécuritaire ou investir en crypto là de
voir ça à l'espace d'une fin de semaine
exploser de façon spectaculaire
qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé vous avez combien de temps en
gros en gros tu le PDG s Bank mfed av
une compagnie d'investissement crypto
qui s'appelait all research euh qui
supposément avait réussi à faire de
l'argent en misant sur la différence sur
le prix du Bitcoin entre le le marché
nordaméricain et le marché en Corée euh
bref on sait pas si c'est vrai mais il a
réussi à avoir beaucoup d'argent il a
fondé FTX puis c'était supposé d'être
séparé donc sa compagnie research ça
être une compagnie à part de FTX il
avait même nommé sa blonde à l'époque
PDG d'Amid Suppé avoir un parf entre les
deux c'était pas le cas puis alamida
allait prendre l'argent des dépôts donc
tu mettais 10000 dollars en Bitcoin sur
FTX ben aut il prenaient ton Bitcoin
dans ton compte tu avais encore 10000
dollars
h il
prêtaidisid all faire des bêes sur le
marché de la crypto puis quand le marché
montait cétait il faisait de l'argent
gratuit c'était comme c'était des génies
qui avaient réussi à trouver une formule
pour générer de l'argent infini prendre
l'argent de quelqu'un d'autre l'investir
puis en faire cher les profits puis
quand la personne veut retirer son
argent tu fa juste lu donner le problème
c'est quand le marché commence à planter
là ça marche plus puis ce qui est arrivé
ben c'est ça c'est qu'il se sont
retrouvé avec un immense trou dans leur
dans le dans le les finances de FX où il
av prêté toutes les dépôts de leurs
clients ou une grande proportion des
dépôts de leurs clients à leur compagnie
sur puis ben le Mané les gens pouvaient
plus retirer le argent fait qu'il ont
été obligés de bloquer tous les de
bloquer tous les retraits tous les
transferts puis là ben depuis ce tempsl
ben les gens sont sont dans l'inconnu le
le procès de s Bank mfed est supposé de
commencer en octobre octobre novembre
euh il fait face à plusieurs chefs
d'accusation puis je veux dire quand
même il cour le risque de passer le
reste de sa vie en prison ben c'est ça
donc explosion spectaculaire d'un des
compagnies les plus en vu disons que je
pense que ça miné beaucoup la la la la
confiance des gens env le système de
crypto là parce vendu comme un un
système financier parallèle qui est
décentralisé c'est on on sort du
contrôle des grandes banques le système
économique qui est piégé contre vous ben
là on bâti ensemble un nouveau système
économique qui va être va travailler
pour les gens par le peuple pour le
peuple h puis là on se rend compte que
ben finalement l'humain reste un humain
à fin l'histoire c'est c'est gangrainé
de fraude cet écosystème là ouais h je
dire quand tu regardes les quand tu
regardes les les les les origines de
Bitcoin c'est quand même fascinant
l'idée derrière ça ça émergé suite au
crash financier de 2008 2009 en disant
regarde les banques ont tout bousillé le
système financier on va trouver une
manière dé contourner
se retrouver 13 ans plus tard avec les
les compagnies de crypto ont fait la
même chose on fait je tu regardes
comment FTX s'est planté c'est à peu
près semblable à qu'est-ce qu' a fait
planter fin c'est c'est une bulle puis
avec toutes sortes de d'instruments
financiers complexes que les gens ont
créé puis celle-ci je parla Celsus
tantôt la compagnie dans laquelle la
CDPQ investi des 150 millions de dollars
US ben c'était c'est une compagnie qui
offerit des prêts en en crypto fait que
tu pouvais aller euh mettre la crypto
emprunter de l'argent tu pouvais mettre
la crypto emprunter d'autres crypto hm
hm c'est un peu la même chose qui a fait
planter Wall Street en 2008 2009 c'est
que des tu fais des prêts des des prêts
de plus en plus risqués puis un Mané ben
quand le marché il baisse puis que les
gens arrêtent de repayer leur prêt ben
toute plante puis tout le monde perd
tout l'argent tu sais céit c'est fou
c'est comme en en 12 ans ils ont juste
répété toutes les mêmes erreurs puis ils
sont arrivés au même résult
ouais exactement ouais perdre perdre tes
économies au complet dans ça là ça doit
être une des choses les plus horribles à
vivre h mais c'est qu'il y avait
tellement de monde on dirait que c'était
pu tu sais l'espèce de de genre
stéréotype crypto Bro là les les les
gars qui faisaient juste parler de ça
mais il y a du monde c'était devenu il
sont tellement embarqué vite dans
patente en pensant je sais pas la
promesse d'opportunité on dirait qui
dans n'importe quoi on dirait que dans
n'importe quoi faut que tu prennes ton
temps là dans n'importe quoi faut que tu
le regardes aller mais il y en a qui ont
comme qui ont embarqué là dedans c
devenu comme le leur personnalité moi il
y a un gars que j'ai arrêté de voir à
cause que il me parlait de ça à toutes
les tit fois je le voyais ouais je
l'éviter après parce que c'estit comme M
je peux pas passer une heure avec toi
c'est ça a pas de sens regarde ça de son
côté tu sais participer à créer un
nouveau système financier il y a quelque
chose de quand même incroyablement faut
tout le monde faut que tu
tu tu es en train de créer quelque chose
de nouveau dans ta tête ça va être le
nouveau système financier on va
remplacer les banques puis ça c'est il y
a des gros problèmes avec le système
financier en ce moment il y a des gens
qui sont exclus par le système financier
qui peuvent pas chercher des prêts qui
peuvent pas puis des compagniesus
disaient on fait pas d'enquête de crédit
tu peux emprunter de l'argent et pas de
problème c'est vraiment séduisant puis
tu sais tu regarde les statistiques aux
États-Unis par exemple le le le crypto
Bro stéréotypé c'est un gars genre de
classe moyenne blanc qui qui conduit une
Ferrari mais les statistiques c'est
quelque chose comme 10 % des blancs aux
États-Unis avaient de la crypto 20 % des
Noirs avaient de la crypto pourquoi
parce que le système financier a
historiquement discriminé contre les les
les les communautés noires aux
États-Unis pouvaient pas aller chercher
des prêts là tuas les gens qui arrivent
ben nous on est en train de btir quelque
chose de nouveau puis investis avec nous
autres parce que genre nous on
discrimine pas on check même pas ton
identité avant tu as donner des prêts
c'est super séduisant pu c'est plate
parce queil y a plein de gens qui se
sont embarqués là-dedans de bonne fois
qui ont été complètement livés par ces
compagnies là tu sais c'est c'est je
sais qu'on a le stéréotype d'un crypto
Bro avec sa Ferrari puis qui dit à tout
le monde have fun staying pour puis tu
sais genre c'est pas c'est vraiment pas
juste ça les gens qui ont investi en
cryp puis c'est une conséquence aussi là
du fait que ben il y a des problèmes
avec le système financier
actuelis mais tu sais puis moi c'est
c'est
les NFT là que c'est un concept que j'ai
que j'ai de la misère à pas voir pas
trouver de l'absurdité là-dedans puis tu
sais c'est juste j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a comme un genre de quelque chose de
pyramidal làdedans dans le sens que plus
il y a un engouement pour ça plus on en
parle plus on russit à embarquer des
gens là-dedans mais là plus ça prend de
la valeur puis là c'est mett on le vu
avec les les fameux B les singes là tu
sais c'est comme le gros h toutes les
célébrités achent ça wou ça fait mon la
valeur puis suffit qu' quelque chose qui
arrive pour que comme ce qui valait 2
millions en vaut en va du 100000 mais tu
sais c'est comme puis tu sais pour
quelque chose qui est intangible
finalement c'est comme si j'ai réussi à
te convaincre et la roche là là que j'ai
trouvé dans le parking là est tellement
malade C roche
là genre pu là j'essaie je réus à
convaincre assez de monde que la roche
est dé vaut vraiment cher puis il y a
une enchè finalement j'ai réussi à
vendre la roche 10000 pièces juste parce
que j'ai réussi à convaincre le plus de
monde possible que la roche est
incroyable quand que j'ai trouvé dans le
parking tu sais c'est tellement abstrait
que ça quelque chose bizarre làdedans je
dirais aussi que c'est la nature humaine
tu sais quand j'étais jeune les cartes
d' h ouais ouais c'est un bout de carton
avec une photo d'un athlète ou oui c'est
un objet qui est tangible mais tu sais
j'avoue que ça pas de valeur intrin la
valeur qu'on lui accorde comme tout
finalement tu av genre la la carte rooky
de Wayne grsky qui valait je sais pas
combien de milliers de dollars mais si
tu voyais ça comme un investissement tu
l'achetais tu t'attendais à ce que
quelqu'un te l'achète plus cher que toi
tu l' achetéit ça aussi c'est pyramidal
c'est faut tout le temps que tu trouves
quelqu'un qui est prête à l'acheter plus
cherman c'est où la limite la même chose
avec dollars tu sais comme une peinture
de Picasso que tu achètes 8 million de
dollars si tu veux faire un profit il
faut que tu trouves quelqu'un qui va t'
acheter plus ch c'est juste j'ai
l'impression que Picasso fait ses
preuves dans le sens que une valeur a
une valeur culturelle ouiis sais j'ai
pas l'impression mais peut-être que un
jour les valeurs des Picasso vont
complètement chuter là ça va se vendre
sa piè sur le bord de la rue peut-être
mais j'ai moins l'impression que des
images générées parateur mais tu vois
les BAPE avait pour certaines personnes
une valeur culturelle dans le sens que
tu faisais partie d'un club tu étais
invité dans des des party VIP qui où
fallait que tu montres la preuve que tu
détiens un board pour pouvoir rentrer
dans dans les party il y avait justement
des célébrités qui étaient entré tu P
faire partie d'un club avec M&M puis
Snoop Dog là quand
mêmeis ouais
tout ça a été orchestré fort
probablement des célébrités comme Jimmy
Fall tout on sait maintenant que leurs
agents disposait d'investissement dans
openc qui est une des plus grandes
plateformes pour vendre chez des NFT
puis que disons que cétait peut-être la
promotion pas 100 % déclaré sais c'était
pas 100% organique là mais c'est que je
comprends là
Mo j'ai fait un podcast série plus sur
le monde de la crypto où on en parlait
de l'absurdité de la chose parfois puis
de la fraude puis tout mais faut aussi
voir qu'il y a des gens qui rentre
là-dedans sincèrement en voulant changer
les choses en voulant participer à
quelque chose de nouveau puis oui en
voulant profiter tu sa de changer leurs
circonstances de dire ben le rêve que tu
as acheté un bardape au MIN price à 1200
dollars US puis que là il vaut 1 million
ouais ça change ta vie du jour au lemain
c'est comme gagner la loterie tu sais
les gens achte quand même des billets de
lterie même si ch ça reste que ça reste
que c'est plus du gambling que de
l'investissement je ve dire des fois tu
pard des fois tu gagnes mais tu sais
c'est pas comme on a fait un podcast
hier sur l'investissement en bourse là
tu sais puis je veux dire c'est pas
comme juste acheter ton ton SNP 500 puis
dans ton fond puis laisser ça murir
pendant 30 ans puis après ça tu pe
prendre ta retraite là c'est comme c'est
du gambling dans le fond tu sais toas du
risque toutes les investissements du RIS
mais du mais l'affaire avec ça c'est que
il y a de track record comme on parlait
de l'art avec Picasso tu sais on sait
les tendances de ça là les NFT la crypto
c'est arrivé tellement vite qu'on savait
pas c'était quoi les tendances
d'investissement là tu sais puis on le
sait pas encore
aujourd'hui aussi des promesses tu sais
que on promettait aux gens que quand tu
achètes un board tu détiens les droits
d'auteur puis que si quelqu'un veut
faire la marchandise tu peux faire de la
marchandise avec ton board puis avoir
toutes les les royautés puis tout ça ça
c'était comme encodé dans l' NFT tu les
droits d'auteur mais mais en vérité on
sait pas si vraiment ça serait reconnu
par les systèmes Lego comme c'est che ça
reste che quand même c'estoup cétait
beaucoup d'idées qui étaient
avantgardistes disons comme ça qui ont
été déployé probablement un peu trop
rapidement comme tu dit l'idée d'un
objet digital numérique qui est unique
je il y a une idée intéressante derrière
le concept même techologie derrière la
crypto est fabuleuse dans sens que c'est
une vraiment bonne manière de
d'éviter de des données ou d'encrypter
des données tu sais mais ouais mais
c'est ça tuis il y a des idées les gens
qui ont créé le Bitcoin c'était des
activistes sais c'était c'était pas des
gens qui voulaient s'acheter des Ferrari
là céit des gens qui étaient comme la
finance débarque sur Internet les
gouvernements vont nous surveiller il
faut trouver une façon de transférer de
la richesse sans se faire bloquer sans
sans se faire surveiller cétait c'était
vraiment une un projet politique plus
qu'autre chose il y a quelque chose de
fascinant derrière ça l'idée est quand
même j'ai gnial en quelque part de tu
réussis à transférer de la valeur sans
qu'il y ait une autorité centrale qui
dise oui tu as le droit il y a quand
même quel il ont ont réussi à résoudre
un problème fondamental tu quand même
assez intéressant maintenant c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il ont fait avec qu'est-ce
que la communauté a fait avec l'idée des
NFT aussi il y a quelque chose de
vraiment intéressant d'un point de vue
technologique ou même conceptuel de
genre on crée un objet numérique qui est
unique qui peut auquel on peut attribuer
une valeur parce que sur internet tu
peux copier coller des photos mais
il existe c'est un objet numérique il y
a une idée intéressante derrière ça
maintenant en vérité en vérité ben un
NFT c'est un lien vers une image c'est
ça exact c'est ça fait gen si le lien
disparaît ton NFT il y a plus d'image
dedans si quelqu'un réuss à hacker
l'image puis remplacer avec quelque
chose d'autre mais ton NFT c'est ça
maintenant mais quand même l'idée
derrière ça tu sais il y a quand même
quelque chose d'intéressant là mais
l'avantage de la technologie derrière la
crypto c'est pas justement ça que c'est
c'est c'est presque impossible à hacker
non parce que les données sont commeties
surtous les utilisateurs qui ça crée un
réseau que ouais ouais c'est ça c'est tu
le NFT en tant que tel tu pourrais pas
aller le modifier sans contrôler
le 51 % des ordinateur qui valide la
chaîne de bloc mais le lien sur lequel
l'image est hébergée est-ce qui est
aussi sécure que ça pas tout le
temps pas tout le temps c'est ça la
quelque part c'est que tu sais le NF en
tant que tel tu pourraas pas aller
changer l'URL dedans mais l'image en
tant que tel est-ce que si si la
personne arrête d'héberger cette image
là dans 50 ans parce que les choses
disparaissent sur Internet ben tu sais
c'est
ça conceptuellement c'est quand même
quelque chose d'intéressant mais tu sais
c'est ça c'est c'est pas parfait j'
quand même un Picasso avir un NFT du
même prix ben il a
po Aché une carte Magic à 2 million
quand même h là c'est fou il y en a
juste une ben ça c'est h là ouais c'est
un Canadien qui l'a trouvé en plus la
vidéo est-ce qu' trouve o est-ce qu'
ouvre le booster pack puis là
trouve c'est 00 sur 00 ça ch une
vie j'ouvrais gen boost pack de Magic
j'avais genre une carte foil puis je
paniqu 40 pièces 20 pièces tu comme W
j'ai carte à 20 pièces 2 millions
tuagines après ça tu l'as faire en
j'espère qu' va la faire en pour au
moins joue à Magic c'est ça c'est un
trip un tripe de Magic puis il y a cet
argent là tu sais et je l' entendais
justement sur le Podcast de Joe Rogan il
parlait de lui sa plus grande peur par
rapport à l'intelligence artificielle
c'est que
euh maintenant mettons le monde dans là
on peut encore entendre quand qu'une
œuvre est créée par l'intelligence
artificielle mettons j'ai entendu je
pense c'était Donald Trump qui chante
summer time sadness de l'ANA del r tu
sais B puis c'était quand même genre
c'était Donald Trump qui chantait
mais ça paraît encore un petit peu que
c'est c'est du l'intelligence
artificielle mais lui il disait que que
ce qu' pense qu' allait s'en venir puis
qui savait pas trop quoi faire avec ça
CIT quelqu'un allait pouvoir Mons écrire
un prompt qui est
genre je viens de me faire laisser par
ma blonde Jessica puis je me sens triste
gen puis là plus tu mets de détails puis
là l'intelligence artificielle écrit une
Tun de PA Molon qui parle exactement de
ton expérience à toi genre ton
expérience personnelle puis dit une fois
que ça ça devient la patente puis parce
que il dit il y a du monde qui aime mes
tunes parce que c'est c'est des bonnes
des bonnes tunes mais aussi du monde qui
aime mes tunes parce que c'est moi qui
font c'est moi qui est fait puis dit là
il y a du monde qui vont pouvoir juste
commander sur recommande une Tun encore
plus précise de ta propre situation avec
un artiste que tu aimes puis tout ce
monde là ils auront plus besoin de moi
là tu sais ils auront plus besoin
d'artistes comme ça parce qu'ils vont
pouvoir écouter exactement ce qu'ils
veulent quand ils veulent tu sais ouais
je pense pas qu'on est rendu là là tu
sais pas là encore là tu sais on parle
souvent de chansons générées par
intelligence artificielle mais faut
garder en tête que c'est pas vraiment
c'est plus des filtres de voix là fa
ouais pour l'instant ouou c'est
quelqu'un qui va chanter puis qui va se
mettre un fil de Donal Trump ou quelque
chose comme ça de générer une chanson
100 %. peut-être qu'un jour vont les
gens vont écouter ça mais tu sais les
gens écoutent la musique pas juste pour
du avoir du bruit de fond là tu sais le
monde va ressentir une connexion pu
c'est souvent les gens vont aimer
l'artiste quasiment autant que l'art
mais non mais c'est c'est c'est
justement ça c'est c'est ça que lui il
mentionne comme comme problème si le
monde même moi m qui écoute les musiques
la musique que j'aime pu écoute la
musique parce que c'est moi ben s'ils
sont capables de m'avoir moi qui fait
quelque chose qui est encore plus proche
de leur expérience personnelle mais ils
auront plus besoin de moi tu sais c'est
un peu ça son affaire mais je comprends
qu'on qu'on en est probablement loin
ouais je veux pas être le gars qui dit
ça arrivera jamais puis là finalement on
sort la clip dans 5 an comment il C mais
mais on est famous pour faire ça
ressortir des vieilles entrevues puis
honnêtement je vois pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui tu sais on est si on est
capable de de dire à chat GPT écris-moi
un scénario de film avec tel tel tel
hisoire tel personnage dans le style de
un tel puis tu décris assez bien puis
qui fait quelque chose de correct de pas
pire mettons là que tu peut-être que tu
travailles mais de toute façon c'est ça
vient de naître cette affaire là je vois
pas pourquoi tu pourrais pas dire euh
écris-moi une Tun où est-ce que les
violons sont quand même importants dans
le style de Cold Play mais qui parle de
telle affaire puis que le bridge euh va
sur tel accord puis nana puis qui tu qui
te le fait je dire moi vous l' pas tu
sais vous le vraiment pas tant longtemps
je disais tu sais jamais l'intelligence
artificielle va pouvoir
imiter des voix m là je oui c'est vrai
que c'est quand
même tu sais ça a été chanté puis là on
remplace la voix mais c'est quand même
c'est quand même impressionnant quand
même ce que ça fait là tu sais il y a un
artiste mettons qui qui composé une Tun
puis là il dit préférez-vous ma tune
chantée par Kurt CIN dupa ou tel autre
personne tu sais plus trois versions de
la tunne avec les voix puis tu sais jeux
dire cit pareil là tu sais quelque chose
puis pas longtemps je dis jamais qu'on
va capable de faire ça on le fait tu
sais
fait j'ai quand même l'impression que à
vitesse où la technologie puis le monde
évolue je vois pas pourquoi ça
existerait pas là tu sais ouais écoute
je dis ça en tant que personne qui a
beaucoup interragé on l' chat GPT au
bureau puis on on lu fait faire plein
d'affaires pouresser de voir comment la
machine fonctionne puis je te dirais que
tu te rends compes assez rapidement des
limites en tout cas actu
P qui est quand même pas si vieux que ça
là pour moi en ce moment des choses
comme chat GPT c'est c'est un tour de
magie c'est c'est ça donne l'impression
que c'est super impressionnant ce que
c'est en train de faire mais c'est une
illusion tu sais ouais c'est comme tu
sais un magicien qui prend une carte
puis qui là il a fait disparaître puis
elle apparaît dans ta poche on dirait
que c'est ça qui est arrivé ton cerveau
fait comme wouh c'est incroyable mais
c'est pas ça qui est arrivé c'est un
truc puis sa GPT c'est un peu ça c'est
un truc tu sa c'est ce que c'est c'est
une analyse statistique du langage
humain qui est capable d'établir des
liens entre des choses puis quand tu F
d'une phrase il est capable de dire bon
ben les mots dans cet ord là dans cette
phras là ça génère tel genre de réponse
tu sais puis c'est des c'est vraiment
c'est un modèle statistique pluspd est
pas capable de penser puis quand tu
quand tu comprends ça puis tu fais
générer beaucoup de texes tu te rends
compte comme tu le vois tout de suite tu
sais ma belle-mère qui qui est
professeur d'université elle m'envoie un
courriel que son élève il a écrit pour
parce qu'il a remis son son son devoir
en retard puis a dit il me semble il est
bizarre ce texte là je le regarde ça
pris 3 secondes je comme c'est chat GPT
qui a écrit ça tu le vois il y a tout le
temps les
mêmes c'est dur à c'est dur à expliquer
mais genre tu le vois le niveau de
langage les phrases il ont tout le temps
la même longueur puis le même rythme
c'est tout le temps tout le temps si tu
demandes ch P d'écrire des poèmes par
exemple tu sais au début tu es comme
waouh genre sais j'avais demandé écrit
écrit une t de Bob dein qui parle de
genre l'odysée d'OM genre là ben ça
parle l' de puis ça des mots genre un
peu qui ressemble à Bob de tu es comme
wou c'est vraiment impressionnant mais
quand en Gén plusieurs tu te rends
compes ok ouais non c'est un truc de
magie tu sais c'est vraiment comme ça
donne l'impression que la machine
réfléchi ouais mais il y a aucune
créativité dans le fond c'est ça non
c'est dans le fond c'est ce que ce que
Ch PT a fait c'est que il ont pris des
milliards et des milliards de textes
humains il ont FIDÉ ça puis la machine
développe un modèle statistique de elle
trouve des liens entre des choses puis
fait juste recracher ça a prédit ce que
tu veux entendre par par rapport à son
analyse on parle c'est extrêmement
sophistiqué sais vraiment on simplifie
là mais
elle réfléchit pas la machine fait ça
fait en sorte qu' est super bonne à
certaines choses par exemple Bob DIN
puis l'odysé de mer c'est deux deux
choses qui ont aucun lien ensemble mais
capable de trouver des liens entre ça
parce qu'elle a fait tellement d'analyes
sur des millions et des millions de
textes mais pas de réfléchir don si tu
demande de réfléchir à des problèmes de
résoudre des problèmes qui sont quand
même qui sortent de l'ordinaire ou qui
nécessitent de
réfléchir il est plus capable ch sais
puis ça cause problème aussi parce que
ben c'est ça ilrache plein d'erreur là
on sa c'est absolument fou c'est n chat
GPT d'écrire par exemple ma biographie
euh parce que tu sais j'ai il y a des
informations à mon sujet en ligne mais
pas énormément il y a pas énormément
d'articles qui ont été écrit à mon sujet
mais chatp va juste inventer des il va
inventer des affaires c'est ça il va
dire que je me rappelle dernière fois
j'ai essayé ça disait que que j'avais
gradué l'Université de Toronto pas vrai
puis ça disait que j'avais animé des
émissions de radio pas vrai mais ce que
c'est c'est que CHP comprend que je suis
journaliste à Radio Canada que j'ai un
nom anglophone puis là dans sa tête dans
son modèle statistique ben des
journalistes qui ont des noms
anglophones mais il y a une grande
chance qu' ont gradué l'Université de
Toronto il pige dans toutes les toutes
les biographies du journaliste anglophon
qui ont été écrit tu sais c'est comme
c'est ça quand tu quand tu vois un peu
derrière le rideau de la machine tu te
rends compes ok il y a quelque chose de
c'est pas que c'est pas impressionnant
parce que quand tu sais comment un truc
de magie est fait ça peutme
y a une certaine il y a une mécanique y
a une habilité sais puis ce que Open en
fait ave GPT ça c'est complètement fou
c'est impressionnant d'un niveau
technologique mais c'est ça ça ça ça
donne l'impression que la
machine qu'elle a un esprit tu sais puis
en en a pas fait juste recracher c'est
ça son son analyse statistique du
langage humain ou ouais je comprends
mais il y a quand même des applications
peut-être pas GPT mais tu sais les
applications de lé en général qui déjà
peuvent remplacer l'humain dans
certaines sphères là tu sais euh on en
parlait une fois là tu sais quand qu'on
était plus jeune il y a un gars qu'on
connaissait je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'il
faut aujourd'hui peut-être qu'il fait
encore ça il faisait des pochettes
d'album de métal tu sais il faisait des
estis de belles pochettes Pascal lacur
son nomouis puis tu sais c'est vraiment
des de dessin qui devait prendre une
éternité à faire avec un souci du détail
incroyable
je sais pas combien de temps ça devit
pendre bref aujourd'hui je tu peux
générer ça en point 2
secondes journey affair comme ça on
avait fait quand qu'on parla de ça genre
j'avais écrit Dave grow comme personnage
de Mario Kart puis ce que ça m'a donné
j'aurais même pas su mett mettons que
c'était ça je voulais comme pochette
d'album puis j'aurais même pas su quoi
demander
de différent à un artiste tu sais m
j'avais j'avais exactement ce que je
voulais j'aurais pas su quoi faire de
mieux ou quoi modifier pour que ce soit
plus de mon goût céit comme en un prompt
à peu près 30 secondes temps de générer
puis ça venait de faire mon cover
d'album puis c'est quand même inusité
comme Prom tu sais mais ouais
effectivement
çaand j'ai vu ça quand j'ai commencé à
gser avec mid journey j'ai fait je pense
plus que je vais jamais avoir besoin
coup d'illustrateur d'illustrateur dans
le fond écoute c'est ça c'est sûr que il
y a beaucoup de gens qui vont au moins
tenter de remplacer des jobs avec ça tu
sais même si ça fait pas la job à 100 %
tu sais on en a déjà vu là genre tu as
partagé une photo sur sur Twitter
dernièrement c'est genre une compagnie
qui fait genre si vous voulez avoir du
fun au travail c'est juste du monde
comme qui qui ont l'air vraiment
en arrière genre une
monstruosité
uneille
en horrible assurezvous dis si vous êtes
pour
utiliser onait
monstre mais c'est
ça quand Mme que je vous dis que les
résultats de chatpt tout c'est pas si
impressionnant que ça si pour certaines
compagnies ou certaines personnes c'est
juste assez bon pour que ça passe ils
vont ils vont remplacer les jobs avec ça
c'est un blogur qui a besoin d'écrire un
article amené je pense li Primot sur son
site web dis je donne au monde 25 pièces
pour un article puis genre de 250 m plus
besoin de personne qui va écrire un
article de 250 mots là tu as besoin
d'une personne qui est capable d'en
pondre 50 en une journée
on a trouvé des des des publicités sur
des sites de de de de vente de maison là
il sont carrment écrit parbt on sa parce
qu'il ont on par accident il ont copié
collé le regenerate
responseou euh des des des annonces de
toutes sortes des des des des sites de
dropshipping j'ai même vu je vous jure
un gars qui a écrit un un message
prononcé le décès de sa mère avec Ch GPT
sur facebook là
message touchant pour ma
belleère quoi dire pour mes vœux à mon
mariage tuas plein de on a trouvé un
exemple je l'avais partagé sur Twitter
mais une ville aux États-Unis qui il
font un post pour
commémorer June qui est la fête de la
reconnaissance de l'histoire des Noirs
aux États-Unis puis il ont fait ça par
chat GPT puis tu es comme est-ce que tu
es vraiment sincère pas de sens on
essaie de on veut reconna tre la
communauté noire dans notre V c'est
comme mais te demander à une machine de
te l'écrire genre puis ça vient du cœur
là
clair mais tu quelqu'un qui sa job c'est
de gérer les réseaux sociaux de la ville
qui a probablement été remplacé par chat
GPT sais ça ça arrive très vite pu c'est
ça peu importe si la machine est bonne
ou pas si est juste assez bonne ça va
remplacer des jobs c'est mais c'est pas
je su pas expert sur le le dossier mais
c'est pas aussi un peu à la source de ce
qui se passe à aussi avec les grèves
puis tout ça en ce moment il y avait
ouais c'est une des choses que les
syndicats des des euh des auteurs euh
demandait c'est d'empêcher justement
l'utilisation de de d'intelligence
artificielle dans la création de
scénario il y avait aussi pour la Guil
des acteurs même chose là il voulit les
studios voulaient pouvoir utiliser le
visage ou utiliser le visage puis le le
mettre sur d'autres corps à perpétuité
donc tu fais un film puis après ça il
prennent ton visage sais ouais mais je
pense qu'il y même des contrats qui ont
été signés là tu sais des figurants qui
je va faire une job de figuration puis
finalement tu signes que ils peuvent
utiliser ton ton
visageé au cinéma avec ta BL tu VO ta ta
dans T les films à l'arrière dans juric
World tu fais poigner par un
vé dinosaure volant c'est sûr qu' vont
essayer c'est sûr qu' vont essayer de
l'utiliser s peuent des des corporations
tu sais tu as déjà il y a une émission
de Marvel avec Samuel Jackson le non
m'échappe mais le générique a été en
partie créé par mid journey là
oua au autres il ont dit que c'était
pour donner un look tu sais parce que
c'est un c'est c'est un ça marchait
thématiquement avec le thème de
l'émission puis mais c'est aussi cool
que ça coûte rien mais ça pas été 100 %
généré par l'intelligence AR mais tu
vois sais il on le pied dans porte de
genre ok mais là on est peut-être
capable de générer des images avec ça
puis et oui ouais mais c'est comme
Amazon qui est complètement pollué de
livres de livres pour enfants qui sont
juste générés
par exactement tu
saisou tu peux publier un livre en une
heure des compagnies de dropshipping qui
décid mettons un gars là dans son salon
en bobette là qui qui fait générer un
livre pour enfants par chat GPT puis mid
journey qui fait imprimer ça à n'importe
quel imprimeur là ça te prend 2 secondes
à trouver ça puis qui fait un drop
chipping par une compagnie qui s'occupe
de la logistique là le gars il est dans
ses bobettes là il est assis chez
rien c'est sûr que c'est tellement
pollué que ça va devenir de plus en plus
difficile de faire avec ça là mais mais
ouais tu en là tu en as déjà tu cherches
sur Amazon pour regenerate response tu
vas en trouver plein des Liv comme ok ça
c'est créé par chat GPT à 100000ur il y
a un gars quand chat GPT est sorti il il
a genre demandé à chat GPT j'ai d 100
pièces puis je veux Builder la la
compagnie jusqu'au plus haut profit
genre puis là il interag avecpt dis non
là ça tu as pas raison genre je propose
t affire puis il faisait un trend sur
sur j'ai arrêté de le suivre après une
Coupe de journée là mais àé il était
rendu quand même loin là son plan d'
genre là il disait e en passant chat GPT
maintenant que j'ai commencer à faire ça
là il y a genre 10000 personnes qui me
suivent sur Twitter depuis fait que
qu'est-ce que tu penses de ça pu dis je
pense que tu devrais commencer à
demander à des gens s'ils veulent
financer le truc fait que là il était
rendu à genre une compagnie il faisait
tout ce quept disait puis il était rendu
gen une semaine à de quoi de vraiment
solide avec plein d'investisseurs je sa
pas je sais pas il rendu j'ai arrêté de
suivre mais je sais que sa compagnie
avait généré profit négatif parce qu'il
avait investi de l'argent dans les
publicités tout puis la porte c'est
revenue céit justement des gens qui
étaient tombés qui suivait le trend sur
twitterp sen rendait compte aussi que il
s rendait compte je veux
dire lui il disait à chpt qu'il y avait
du monde qui
Fall comme C il y a de l'argent à faire
des fait des pubs genre sur Twitter il
faisait genre ah fait que là il y a une
pub pour telle compagnie parce que genre
merci à telle compagnie de financer mais
chat GPT il prenait ça son équation
c'est quand même débile
ouais ben tu sais c'est ça
c'est tu sais on on disait tantôt que le
monde de la crypto a comme baissé là
c'est le ai là fait que là tout le monde
est là-dessus sais tu le vois là les
gars qui faisait des cours
d'investissement en crypto sur Youtube
mais là c'est comment comment faire 1000
pièces par jour avec chat GPT tu sais
mais ça aussi il y a de quoi de
séduisant de participer à la création de
quelque chose de nouveau qui va changer
le monde puisouais reste à voir mais
mais toi tu es tu es tu es pas alarmiste
clairement par rapport à ça mais tu
l'impression que ça va changer le monde
en fait c'est que j'ai comme je
m'inquiète que on on tu sais les
inquiétudes c'est comme chat GPT va
remplacer
comme tout le monde puis que c'est çarep
qui va prendre les décisions pour le
gouvernement puis les robots vont nous
contrôler quelque chose deors le réel
risque c'est que des jobs fasses
remplacer par des ordis qui font pas une
si bonne job que ça tu sais tu pourrais
imaginer un scénario où tuas des
compagnies qui disent bon ben le service
à la clientèle c'est chat GPT puis chat
GPT des fois il donne des mauvaises
réponses il t'aide pas il comprend pas
ta question mais s'ils veulent parler à
un être humain faut qu'il paye tu sais
package premium de sais comme je
m'inquiète que beaucoup de gens auraient
accès à des services de
qualité par créé par des psychologues
virtuels ou tu sais même des
consultations de médecins virtuels ou
des professeurssh de primaire
virtuel parce que ça coûte rien ben les
pauvres ont accès à ça puis les gens
plus fortunés ben ils peuvent se payer
un médecin une vrai un vrai médecin un
vrai prof puis un vrai psychologue ça tu
un réel un réel risque de dystopie là
euh déjà dans un contexte où les
inégalités sociales sont quand même
assez fort là puis là je veux dire les
compagnies cherchent tout le temps à
optimiser leur profit puis là ça ça
vient de leur donner un cadeau de dire
des choses qu'on pouvait pas faire avant
même si je disais tantôt que chat GBT
réfléchit pas vraiment il donne
l'illusion de pouvoir réfléchir puis il
fait des choses que les programmes fait
pas faire avant ça va les les inciter à
essayer de remplacer des gens avec ça
quit à avoir des services qui sont moins
bons mais as long as good enough ben tu
sais c'est ça fait je d'avoir des vraies
conséquences puis aussi pour tout ce qui
est FRUD spam d'être capable de dire à
chat GPT de contacter des gens puis
d'avoir des conversations avec eux pour
les convaincre à t'envoyer de l'argent
tu sais comme sais des des des des
scamers devait doivent dépenser beaucoup
de temps à tu sais créer un faux site
webcrire le email de du du
princeab c'est ça le prince nigérien
ouais c'est ça là c'est même plus le là
c'est c'est c'est parce que tu souent
des scamers qui sontons Philippines ils
veulent ils veulent targeter des
Canadiens tu sais ils connaissent pas la
culture canadienne ils parlent pas
français ou anglais ils savent pas là
ils ont juste besoin de dire à chat GBT
dans leur propre langue écris-moi un
article sur une célébrité canadienne qui
parle d'un élément d'actualité qui se
passe au Canada c'est on est déjà là là
fait tu sais comme puis pour des
applications de spam puis de scam des
choses comme ça le fait que chatibt est
pas super bon c'est pas un problème
c'est déjà le c'est déjà ça exact exact
exact c'est déjà meilleur que ce que les
autres faisaient à la base ça on le voit
déjà tu sais ça pour de vrai on le voit
déjà on travaille là-dessus je peux pas
trop en parler mais tu sais on le voit
déjà que il y a des gens qui utilisent
ces outils là pour essayer d'aller
d'aller arnaquer des gens pour eux s le
seul obstacle pour les scamers pu les
spammers c'était que ça prenait du temps
puis de l'argent créer du contenu tu
sais écrire un article fallait que
tuengages quelqu'un sur fiver pour
écrire un article de journal fallait que
tu sais tu trouves des photos
puis là maintenant c'est plus besoin
plus besoin de rien payer on besoin de
payer un abonnement à chat GPT à genre
20 pièces par mois puis il peu générer
infini de contenu infiniment rapidement
sais puis non seulement ça créer des
chat bot tu ples dans le P chat GPT puis
chat GPT va parler à ta victime pour toi
tu sais fait ça c'est des choses que qui
sont vraiment inquiétantes sais puis
c'est ça le problème c'est on s'égare
peut-être un peu en regardant trop loin
dans le futur en disant ah maisat GPT là
ça va complètement changer toutes les
industries que ouais mais il y a déjà
des conséquences maintenant là puis ça
s'en vient très très très rapidement hm
hm c'est ça on n'est pas rendu à Skynet
mais ça sent bien s mais puis tu sais
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu le
même problème aussi qu'avec les euh les
mtil naational justement qu' parlait
plutôt comme comme M ou comme Google pu
tout ça c'est que d' la technologie tout
le temps euh euh en avance sur la
compréhension de du citoyen moyen puis
des gouvernements aussi donc
quand que c'est le temps de de de
légiférer ou de d'encadrer tout le temps
trop tard parce que ça a déjà pris
tellement d'ampleur mais mais c'est un
peu la même chose là tu là en ce moment
faut rencadrer ça mais c'est comme le
l'oiseau c'est déjà envolé là c'est pas
c'est pas juste ça c'est aussi mais là
si on encore trop ça on va freiner
l'innovation est-ce que tu veux vraiment
que tu fais une loi au Canada là qui
bannit l'intelligence
artificiellef ouais là tu te retrouves
que Ben la Chine des États-Unis puis l'
des autres travaillent sur
l'intelligence artificielle puis nous
non fait qu'on va avoir un déficit
technologique envers les autres pays
genre si c'est la si c'est la nouvelle
chose qui va changer le monde est-ce
qu'on veut vraiment mettre des bâtons d'
roue puis tu sais c'est extrêmement
c'est extrêmement difficile comme tu dis
même au niveau de la compréhension de
ces outilsl euh pour la population puis
pour les politiciens aussi souvent la
technologie va bien bien bien plus
rapidement que que que qu'on est capable
même de de savoir ce qui se passe tu
sais euh puis de demander à des
politiciens je sais pas si tu as déjà
écouté des politiciens posé des
questions juste à Mark Zuckerberg au
Congrès américain puis tu es comme ces
gens-là sont responsables de légiférer
sur sur la crypto sur l'intelligence
artificielle sur les réseaux sociaux sur
les autos qui se conduisent tout seul
c'est comme ouf il y a du chemin à ouais
ça c'était c'était farf Luu à un bon
niveau là le gars de TikTok aussi là
quand il éit allé aux États-Unis là
ah merci
beaucoup super on va te recevoir dans 3
ans mais on va espérer que onér ton
optimisme vous allez cloner ma voix puis
ouais c'est on aura plus
besoin par Corel les génér généré des
podcasts dans le fond on a plus besoin
ah les gars vous avezrêé de faire du
vidéo ou
ou de
fake fake puis générra notre voix exist
tellement déjà sur le web que dit tous
les mots c'est que ça prend une minute
une minute à faire ouais avec El Labs là
une minute on l' fait avec notre
animateur Alexis de lanceur une minute
de deudo puis on a pu générer sa voix pu
dire n'importe quoi ouais mais tu il y a
des paramètres puis un accent français
mais ouais assez surprenant ou une
minute de di fa vous autes vous avez des
heures et des heures he Deo
ou c'est incroyable je pourrais dire de
de de couper toutes les T puis les
genres que je dis en général je parler
encore mieux c'est incroyable merci
beaucoup ciao merci